okay correct me please representative
espia but that's a valant effort all
right thank you it was if I wasn't so
muffled it would have been perfect thank
you um he is sitting in for
representative Sandler so
welcome and uh my the morning is members
using devices in this room please turn
off the sound to avoid feedback consider
turning off your video if you intend to
use the keyboard for taking notes for
good sound quality it is important for
members to speak clearly with some
volume soft voices may be heard but hard
to understand the microphones in the
room pick up sound very well be careful
about side conversations people let me
know that this mic is working I tend to
turn it off and on and forget about it
uh the computer
room the committee room computer will be
muted at lunch break the Committee
Member will mute and unmute it before we
when we resume after lunch
we are streaming on
YouTube um the pre-registration
information for the entire day is
printed out 30 minutes prior to the
first hearing if you miss this deadline
you must still register online however
your name will not be called so once all
pre-registered speakers have testified
please raise your hand and you will be
recognized to speak as chair of the
house election law committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuing to
executive order
2024 this public is this public body is
authorized to meet
electronically uh there is a public
hearing referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today there is also executive session
which may be held on the bills as
noticed and as may be otherwise have
been referred to committee uh please
note that it is a speaker rule that for
voting on bills during uh roll calls
during executive session you need to be
physically present in the room or
present on screen so that your presence
as an individual may be verified for the
oral vote please note that there is no
physical vocation for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting provice with houss RSA
91a and excuse me houss and RSA 91a
those are two separate things and anyone
who has a problem accessing the meeting
should call 271 3600 or email
HCS
ledge. state. n. Us in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that as I said
before votes taken during this meeting
are done by roll call and phal presence
of the member either in person or on
video who need to be verified let's
start the meeting by taking
both when each member states their
presence if we State whether there
anyone room if meeting requir from under
the right to no law um Lo call
attendance is not officially
reported as for the bill action so CL
Wells if you could just record the roll
thankes I am present I am uh
participating remotely from my home and
there is no one else in the house with
I know good morning I am in my home I'm
you
pres did you say
HL yes yeah H you're a little bit
breaking up I'm Pres I'm in my home and
there's one other family member in the
house representative
H I'm present in my home in Manchester
house yeah representative
Lane I'm presentent in my home office
alone there are two other people on the
house representative McDonald pres
representative Mooney
here representative youread present and
alone representative home O'Brien here
representative qua
knowes yeah espia and my um I am present
alone uh and there's one person in the
house and I'll give you
the representative Sweeney here
representative toosan here
representative
Ward uh here I'm at home with two family
myself my apologies to the committee um
I would like to do the pledges we
normally do at the beginning of our
America
indivisible and jusice for all thank you
everybody we have two items on notice
for executive session at 9:30 121 has
been taken off in a in a revised notice
that you may or may not have seen
um so the only Bill that we have before
us for first thing as it is an early
bill is HB
86 we heard that matter previously it's
relative to voter qualifications and
registration procedures the public
hearing was on January
22 is there a motion on this yes Madam
chairman I'd like to make a motion see
good
representative yes Madam chairman I'm
fellow command members I would movee
that we've attain hb86 I'd like to speak
to a few issues that this bill attemps
to address is there a second to the
motion I second the motion mam chair
representative toosan seconds it
representative Madam chairman in a
recent sanal Institute of politics poll
64% of respondents said they were very
confident in the Integrity of New
Hampshire's election results a different
way of reading this is that a full 36%
of respondents are not very confident in
New Hampshire's election results think
about that for a second over a third of
the people are not very confident in how
we conduct our elections and that should
concern each and every one of
us why is that and how does hb86 relate
to this one of the reasons over a third
of grand estaters are not very confident
in our election results is that we have
the loosest election laws in the country
the quote experts come before us and
tell us that voter fraud does not exist
in New Hampshire what they do not
address is exactly what is voter fraud
as I have pointed out in this committee
someone who is in this state for only 30
seconds can legally vote here in fact 30
seconds is 29 seconds more than you
actually
need when you have a system like ours
which is right for abuse and in fact
does not even label what many people
would constitute as abuse no wonder you
end up with people not having faith in
our elections let me be clear someone
who moves here on Election Day and votes
here and then
decides to another state the next day
does not actually commit a crime in New
Hampshire it is not a law it is not
under our law considered fraud unless
they also voted in their home
state that's our law it's almost
impossible to commit voter fraud in New
Hampshire because what is cons what
should be considered fraud simply
isn't the fact that we have a system
that allows nonresidents to walk into
our polling location register to vote
while presenting no ID no proof of
domicile is actually shameful it is a
New Hampshire specific embarrassment
hb86 attempts to address this often the
Secretary of State's office holds up the
voter age participation statistic where
the
as the number that we should be
concerned about but I am far more
concerned about people believing we have
fair and honest elections than an
arbitrary number that does not begin to
tell the whole story of what is actually
going on the whole story is that while
we have high voter participation we also
have a high degree of skepticism in our
elections and in my opinion the bad is
grossly outling The Good the Secretary
of State office often talks about a
balancing act but right now we are fully
tilted in One Direction and The cost is
people not having faith in the voting
process unfortunately hb86 needs a lot
of work and it's not a clean bill I
appreciate what the sponsors are trying
to do here but they're going about it in
the wrong way and incorporating non-
gerine issues such as trying to suppress
the college student V I hope that this
committee will wake up to the reality
that when a full third of our citizens
are not very confident in our election
that we have a lot of work to do it is
time to end the excuses and get to work
but unfortunately hb86 is an imperfect
vehicle to do this and as such I move
that we retain the bill to continue to
work on
it is there any further discussion on
the um yes Madam chair I have a question
chair um does a vote for this motion uh
indicate any endorsement for the views
of the previous speaker
I I'm sorry I didn't understand the
question representative Cody
you can you repeat it my question was
does a vote for this motion to retain
constitute an endorsement of the views
of the previous speaker no it clearly
does not the motion on the floor
representative Cody um is a motion to
retain that is the entire substance of
the motion that we are voting on thank
you for the clarification for anybody
motion I'm not seeing any I'm going to
ask see I'm gonna ask the clerk to call
the
RO representative McDonald
yes representative food home O'Brien yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
toosan yes representative Barry yes
representative Gro yes representative
Cody with the understanding that the
chair just stated I'll vote yes thank
you representative Cody I need to ask
you to flick your video on WE M of my
party who have been voting terrific
thank you very much that's all we
no representative Bon
yes representative
Lane to be clear we're voting to retain
no representative
frus I vote
no representative H I vote
it's the motion carries 15 five Pam are
if you're online who is showing up on my
screen as
PC you know that's that's just the
computer to your
thank you everybody um we are now moving
on to the morning public
hearings um it is a few minutes after
9:45 and our first public hearing is HB
um representative madori is the sponsor
and has signed in to speak to this
bill
and it's in attendance so welcome to the
morning you should be with us there you
are as a
j if you unmute yourself you should be
all
set great thank you madam chair can you
hear me okay can hear you terrifically
thank you thank you very much members of
the House election law committee I am
Jim majori representing Rockingham
District 22 the town of Northampton
thank you for the opportunity to
introduce hb1 151 a bill that will amend
New Hampshire RSA 654 col 34 such that
the registration of Undeclared voters
who register as members of a party at
any primary shall be returned to
Undeclared registrations by the
supervisors of the checklist after the
close of polls on Election Day this
amendment will simplify Undeclared voter
registration for residents moderators
and the supervisors of the checklist I
urge the committee to move off to pass
on this bill more than 42% of registered
voters in New Hampshire are registered
with the Secretary of State's office as
Undeclared declaring party affiliation
Republican democat or Undeclared is very
simple in New Hampshire a resident
completes a form at their town clerk's
office prior to a date certain in their
city or town registering their party
affiliation when registered Undeclared
voters vote in a state or presidential
primary they will be required to choose
either a Republican or Democratic ballot
at the polls when registered Undeclared
voters vote on that particular party
ballot in a state or presidential
primary they become a registered member
of that party unless they fill out a
card or sign a list to return to
Undeclared status with the supervisors
of the checklist before leaving the
polling
place but what happens if a resident
forgets to change their party
affiliation back to
Undeclared what happens if a resident
wants to support a candidate only to
discover at the polls that their own
party affiliation is inconsistent with
their candidates what happens if a
resident insists they changed their
affiliation back to Undeclared the last
time they voted in a primary but the
last one two three or more checklists
has them listed as either Republican or
Democrat instead
in any of these cases the potential
exists to have a resident who leaves the
polls very angry without having voted or
we have a resident who leaves the polls
very angry having voted on a B on a
ballot contrary to their intentions if
HB 151 passes to simplify the
registration of Undeclared voters the
supervisors of the checklist will return
voter registration back to UND declared
after the close of the polls that day
within the comprehensive reconciliation
of the official checklist residents will
retain their Undeclared status without
any extra paperwork for themselves the
supervisors of the checklist the
moderator or the town clerk if you vote
HB 151 ought to pass we will streamline
the V voter registration process for
residents and officials alike we will
maintain the Integrity of our elections
we will protect the right of every
resident qualified to vote to exercise
their sacred responsibility thank you
and I will be happy to take any
questions thank you representative for
introducing the bill questions for the
representative representative thank you
mad chair than repres Tak my
question on the current bar you V you
vot right to the court or somebody that
working the polls with the supervisor
checklist to change back to Undeclared
you think it's
unburdened to do that
sorry you hear me okay yes I could hear
you I I I thought I interrupted you I
apologize I I thank you for the question
representative um I do not feel no I do
not feel it's a burden uh to repeat that
word I do not feel it's a burden but I
feel this simplifies the process and I
and I say that because I'm responding to
my own town moderator I happen to be a
select been in my town and I've worked
at the polls for each of my four terms
and there have been those instances
where as I've said a a voter has come in
and said well I am registered as or I am
you know I should be this or I should be
that and it creates uh it has at times
created problems for the moderator so
while it is I don't see a burden or I
don't see a a systemic problem what I
would like to see what I would like to
accomplish with this bill is a
streamlining of the process so I I hope
that's responsive to your
question thank you other questions
representative
McDonald thank Madam chairman and good
morning
representative instances in which voter
to I could you repeat the question I'm
sorry
representative um what about those
instances in which may not want to be
returned play status may want to stay
with that
part that's that is a very good question
and and and thank you for that question
uh something I've thought about it's
actually the the antithesis to to what
this is trying to accomplish um and that
process I believe would require the uh
the voter to go to the town clerk as
they would for
Undeclared uh or or any other party to
register their intentions to remain with
that
party thank you thank you other
questions from committee members
committee members attending
video have any
H okay hi representative majori um so my
question is sort of a follow-up to the
previous one do we know how many people
don't want to change back to Undeclared
after they vote they want to stay with
the party do we have any idea like how
many people usually just want to stay in
the one party or the other thank you
thank you representative for the
question my uh my neighbor to the north
it's it's good to see you there hope
you're enjoying your first term um I I
did ATT I did spend some time looking
for statistics uh exactly to your uh to
your question and I was either looking
in the wrong place or just could not
find that to find what those numbers
might be so I apologize that I don't
have the answer to your question but uh
should I be able to find it I'll be
happy to uh to provide that to you and
to the entire Comm thank you sure thank
you further
questions
representative thank you for taking my
question uh just when you said
um changed back that day to
happen th thank you for the question
that would be uh that is the goal that
would be the the purpose that would be
the the the shall the Mandate uh I'm
trying to find the exact right word but
uh it would be the intention here when
the supervisors of the checklist again
are going through that reconciliation
that that change would be made that day
because um well that that would be the
goal
yes thank you sure thank you for the
question any other questions from
committee
do thank you um to follow up on uh
representative Hammer's uh question have
you spoken with uh the folks who run the
things the balloting and the voting
process on that day and have them be
able to change it on that day I mean
shouldn't we give them
time thank you representative for the
question and I um actually it was my
intention to to reach out to many uh
they reached out to me so it was
encouraging to say that uh hearing from
supervisor of the checklist in several
different communities uh that they
thought this process would be uh would
be very readily uh integrated into their
process uh and they would be able to do
it however that said I would certainly
entertain be more than willing to
entertain an amendment if uh if this
committee felt that uh some time certain
some time period might make this easier
I I would be certainly open to that as
it certainly is your bill now I would
conversation thank you thank you
members I'm not seeing any thank you
very much representative for coming this
morning in regards to your bill
hb1 you're welcome and thank you I also
have signed up to speak on this a Bobby
seeing that person in attendance if you
hand I am not seeing that person I do
have two other people who would like to
speak um at this time I'd like to
[Music]
recognize who has indicated a wanting to
register a position on HB 161 you should
with us good morning good morning thank
you so much Madam chair and members of
the election law committee I really
appreciate the time to be here to be
able to speak on this I can say that I
have volunteered as a pole worker at a
small town and have in that role
experience a lot of questions regarding
Undeclared voters as they arrive at the
polling location with the intent to vote
for a specific candidate and as a result
of not having been switched back in the
last election
that they were not able to vote for the
person they intended to on the ballot
that they intended to so with that being
said in a town that had about 800 people
vote uh in the presidential primary that
out of that 800 I would conservatively
say from my personal anecdote that about
15 to 20 people specifically came up uh
in equal proportions from both parties
or who are registered
to uh either of the two major parties
looking to switch to the other major
party in the specific election leaving
themselves to be an Undeclared voter
with the ability to choose which ballot
that they were able to take and were not
able to do so so I can say from my
personal experience that this is an
issue that is been raised by members in
that Community to me I would also like
to speak to an earlier question that was
asked of what happens if someone wants
to remain with a party uh I'd like to
just kind of think of the counterfactual
here so if
someone is an Undeclared voter and they
wishes and they wish to stay with uh
party that they have taken the ballot
from the worst case scenario is that
they are then an Undeclared voter again
in the next election and can still
choose to take the ballot of that party
and have other opportunities to switch
to become that um a member of that party
whereas someone who is an Undeclared
voter
who for whatever rush or whatever reason
that they don't fill out that form at
the end of the day that they come back
to this next election and they are not
able to choose the ballot and vote for
the candidate that they intend to so I
think the counterfactual there is
important and I'd also say that I agree
with the sponsors uh points regarding
simplification of this process uh for
members of the poll team and the uh
supervisor of the checklist uh thank you
so much for the ability to speak and if
there are any questions I'd be welcome
to entertain them thank you for joining
us again is there anybody here in the
committee room who has any questions for
Mr is there anybody attending
questions I'm not seeing any so thank
you also with the request to speak to
this bill is Tiana Coleman
M colan I think if you unmute yourself
you will be with us good morning good
morning thank you for allowing me to
speak uh most of the members of this
committee have seen me speak before but
I'm here representing myself as a
citizen of Amherst and also representing
New Hampshire independent voters which
is fully uh volunteer so I did not get
paid to be here um so um a couple of
things first off we of course support
this bill we are uh Undeclared voters
and this definitely makes the process a
lot easier for us to not have to fill
out the little postcard at the end when
we walk
out uh the question was asked earlier
whether people um how many people intend
to stay with that party but do
not how many people actually intend to
stay with the party whose ballot they
chose and I know that for me and for a
lot of people who I know um even if we
walk out of the voting room that day and
do not fill out the postcard that isn't
actually usually because we intended to
be members of that party it's actually
just because we completely forgot to
fill out the postcard um and so that's
all right put it this
calling can you hear me did you did you
do something differently because in the
committee room your sound just changed I
don't know whether people online notice
that or not can I see any nods were
there any was there a change in her
volume for people online I'm seeing nods
yes so if you can unmute Miss colan
again that would be
great
um I am unmuted can you hear me you're
better now you I I think you might not
have a great connection because you you
froze on the screen for a minute so just
be clearly so we can get you all okay
I'm sorry just let me know again if you
can't hear me I I was saying that
usually if we go out of the of the
ballot room without filling out the
postcard it's because we forgot to fill
out the postcard it's not because we
intended to remain members of the party
in fact I think for the vast majority of
Undeclared
voters I'm not sure they even realize
that they're registering with a party
when they take a ballot because we don't
feel a form that says I hereby register
with this party we just ask for the
ballot that we want and so I think for a
lot of people they're not even clear
that when they walk out of that room
unless they fill out a card they have
now joined a party and so it makes it
much much easier if we just return to
being Undeclared because that's probably
what we want to be if we want to join a
Republican or a Democratic party we
would think that we would need to you
know go officially register with that
party with the with the town clerk so we
think it's a lot easier so we definitely
support this this just makes the process
a lot easier and as to the question as
to whether that's a burden on
the moderators to change it um I'm not
sure if it's actually changed for the
party that day um it seems like we take
a ballot and then we fill out a postcard
on our way out the door and then I
assume that that night or whatever they
go through and everyone who did not turn
in a postcard gets switched to the party
and everyone who did fill out the
postcard gets you know is able to
maintain their status but I could be
wrong maybe that day they frantically
change everyone to democrat or
republican depending on which ballot
they took and then they go through the
postcards and change everyone back but
I'm kind of assuming that they just
change everyone at the same time in
which case there would be a whole host
of people they wouldn't have to really
officially change at least technically
with the computer if they if they just
automatically assume that everyone that
voted Undeclared wants to stay
Undeclared unless they purposely
register with the party
so that's all I really had to say just
that we support this bill makes it much
easier representative to roian thank you
madam chair thank you Miss bman for
taking the question are you aware
whether or not this bill passes or not
you as a voter can contact the town
clerk the town you live at in any time
to determine whether or not you got
change back you haven't you have the
that um I'm not sure if I understood
your question um but I'm assuming that
you know if if this if yes I am aware I
am aware that if I walk out without
filling out the postcard and I forgot I
am aware that I can later go to the town
clerk and change it back I just know
that it's a lot easier if I purposely
when I registered to vote I registered
Undeclared and so it's a lot easier for
me to just assume I'm Undeclared I go
vote and I stay Undeclared unless I go
purposely change it back um I'm also
aware that if this bill passes um you
know then I would just stay UND declared
after I vote and then if I wanted to
join a party I could go to the town
clerk and and choose to join a
party thank you further questions for
committee members in the room
representative McDonald thank you m
how much
responsibility themselves
term that you think it should be mainly
themselves oh I'm so sorry I just could
not understand the question really
clearly I'm sorry it's okay whose
primary responsibility is it for a voter
to determine their political affiliation
the election officials or is it is ited
themselves not CED here based on the
testimony is where that responsible
lives well I mean I think it's it's the
responsibility of the voters to
determine their affiliation um I think
that this bill keeps it that way because
like I said um we've already determined
that we want to be Undeclared and we
don't many of us don't really think of
it as joining a party when we pick a
ballot even though that is technically
what we're doing and so we I we just
think that you know leave us the way we
are unless we purposely say we want to
join a
party thank you further questions from
committee members in the room further
questions from Members attending
electronically I'm not seeing anybody in
this moment for joining us again this
morning is there anybody else in
attendance who wants to speak on
151 please raise your and I'm not seeing
anybody so I am going to close the
public hearing on
151 the next item on our agenda for a
public hearing at
[Music]
o'l House Bill
470 Bill 470 is relative to the
and the prime sponsor of this bill
representative riin that would be Jerry
riin
represent
excuse thank you madam chair and thank
you members of the election Bo committee
I'll be I'll be brief uh this bill
requires the Secretary of State to
highlight the maximum number of votes a
voter May cast for an office um it looks
as if this would just require uh the
Secretary State shall highlight such
phrase using either a different font
color Watermark or other method at the
secretary's discretion uh and that's
what's in the bill and and all I know of
it so I can take questions but that's no
you is there anybody in attendance who
bill any any panelists want to say
anything I am this is not the first time
that sponsor has not been here for the
legislation um in deference to the
unusual circumstances that we're running
this year I am asking somebody and I
don't care who the prime sponsor of the
bill is for somebody to bring it to the
floor um to give sponsors an opportunity
to contact us after after the fact to
deal with it if it's appr
translation um I recognize that in past
circumstances sometimes we have simply
let the bill with on the buy if nobody
comes to introduce us introduce it but
it requires a vote regardless so I my
choice is um to just get it on the floor
regardless of the source and the
committee can then deal with it
as um so House Bill
470 been introduced by representative
sweny I don't see anybody in
attendance or anyit members present with
me or electronically who wish to speak
to
it representative board did you have
your hand up on Sor uh thank you madam
chair I just had a question um I guess
for representative Sweeny what what do
you suppose they mean by watermark in
I'm not sure let me I think I see Deputy
scan on the line here do you
idea uh Deputy scan what they might need
by
Watermark hold on let
me Watermark is is a paper Maker's
device it doesn't I don't see how that
applies to this point bills Deputy scam
I'm here now thank you madam chair uh
I'm not sure exactly what the sponsor
means by Watermark I think that based on
the language in the bill it is just
making a point to give the Secretary of
State uh discretion in how uh the phrase
is highlighted you know whether it's a
different font color Watermark or other
method um the statutes generally give
the Secretary of State the authority to
design the ballot uh within you know
some parameters that are established in
stat statute but uh I think that the
sponsor was probably just trying to make
all the options available uh to the
Secretary State to allow him or her to
uh highlight that
phrase thank
bill oh I'm sorry
repres yeah thank you as long as we have
Deputy scandin here I'll ask I guess I'm
trying to understand the reasoning
behind this bill what is the purpose of
it and why is it
needed uh that's a good question
representative Lane I you know I I can
only speculate as to what the sponsor's
intent might be but I have heard uh uh
legislators and others coming in the
office in the past uh just trying to
suggest that the number of offices that
can be voted on uh or the number of
candidates for a pro specific office to
be voted on is highlighted uh and
usually in multi-member districts uh
some of the large towns uh you know have
as many as 10 or 11 State Rep candidates
on the race um and the uh you know the
individuals that are concerned about
this just want to make sure that the
voter uh knows the number of options uh
that they have to vote for um that would
be my guess I'm not trying to speak for
the sponsor uh because I'm you know
again it's just speculation on my part
on what the sponsors
is could I have a followup
please if memory serves me correctly
isn't this already on the ballot I know
it is here in conquer it's already said
how many you can vote
for that's that that's true
representative Lane um I think what the
sponsors trying to do is highlight that
part of the ballot so where it says vote
for not more than three uh they want
that highlighted in either you know a
color or a larger font or something that
makes that stand out to the
voter thank
you any
representative thank you madam chair I
have a question for Mr scalin are you
aware of any states that are doing this
right now
not of course Deputy scan prob isn't
aware of states that have districts for
nine or 10 Representatives either so I
don't know
representative yes another question
thank you madam chair uh would it be
difficult for your office to implement
this in any
way uh that's a good question res Poma
Brian I I I think it would be difficult
it is just one more thing that we would
have to do in terms of Designing the
ballot New Hampshire does have one of
the more complex ballots for State
elections used around the country just
because of the size of Our House of
Representatives for one thing and and
the number of offices that we elect and
I can tell you that it is it is a a
major project to design the ballots and
then proof them and even with all of the
proofing that takes place uh you know we
always find uh an error somewhere and so
to the extent that you know we now have
to uh highlight a certain section of the
ballot it it simply adds to that
complexity thank you further questions
from people in the
all right thank you very much everybody
I'm gonna close the hearing on
470 the next item for public hearing
this morning is House Bill
570 570 is a
bill permitting certain political
organizations to appear on a general
election ballot as a minor party
after having a
nominating committee excuse me a
nominating convention the sponsors are
representative abson and representative
Le Branch if either of those people are
in attendance could they please raise
their
hand representative Abramson joins
us as soon as I press the next button
and if you unmute yourself
representative Aon you are with us
welcome
me representative abson we're all set
good morning at HB
570 let me see if I
can all right uh so this is House Bill
570 this is uh my name is representative
Max Abramson representing Hampton
Hampton Falls and seab Brook um I'm
introducing this bill House Bill 570
which would allow uh minor parties to be
recognized as such after they've uh had
500 people from around the state uh go
in and register as members of that
particular party um the purpose of the
bill is in response to two things and
it's in uh when we brought up ballot
access issues in the past members of
this committee have said both in
hearings and in person um outside of
hearings that there really needs to be
some kind of a process for forming a
minor party Most states uh and I'm sure
somebody is going to send an email or uh
testify how many states have minor
parties uh what's called minor party
status New Hampshire we have you're
either a political organization or
you're a major party there's nothing in
between there's no uh stepping up
process you pretty much have all of the
minor parties have had a difficult time
New Hampshire uh trying to build up
membership because it's very very
difficult New Hampshire to get on the
ballot we one of the 10 most difficult
States for getting on the ballot um and
you have to get 4% of the vote in um
only one of two Statewide offices either
Governor or Senate and um about onethird
of the time there isn't even a senate
race so in 2016 my gubernatorial
campaign broke some national records
for um
percentages um but also broke a
different record it was the first time
in over 20 years that the libertarian
party of New Hampshire had won over 4%
of the vote managed to get ballot access
but that was only for two years so the
libertarian party of New Hampshire and a
few other parties put their candidates
on for Statewide office in an attempt to
get around the very very or bypass a
very difficult process that only minor
parties have to go through which is uh
gathering over 3,000 signatures which
means effectively they have to gather
over 6,000 signatures um which was very
difficult and I would argue dangerous to
do during the Corona virus um right
during the lockdown is when they were
when um the infection rates were highest
um so that created a health hazard and
the Secretary of State's office was
contacted and they said that they wanted
to do something about it but there
wasn't anything in statute allowing them
to do anything so we we we talked with
them the the other issue and I would say
the bigger
issue is the actual processing of
ballots when I went and talked to uh my
town clerk and when I spoke to other
Town clerks and city clerks in nsha and
Manchester um and people working in
those
offices uh there's about a one- Monon
period in August of election years where
they are they have stacks um I don't
have a I don't have a stack with me but
it's it's um
uh about this high for each stack in
cities like Manchester nsha um that they
have to go through for each campaign in
2016 I believe there were five or six
presidential campaigns and they all had
to go through the same
process and U we tried to estimate the
total cost um of processing all of these
um in terms of lost time lost hours and
the amount of money that they spend and
when they're getting hit with that many
all at the same time uh a lot of towns
don't have the money in in their in
their budget to to put everyone on
overtime to do this so some of your some
of your uh smaller town governments have
outsized populations or uh in some cases
you have some towns where um they're
getting a disproportionate number of
these nominating petitions coming in you
have to go through every single one
meticulously
um and only about half get accepted as
valid so they have to go over every
single line item and every address and
check each address that the voter puts
in and compare that with the record so
we spoke with the Secretary of State's
office about a number of different
Alternatives that are used and uh by far
the most coste effective is to Simply
have voters who want to be members of
third parties uh go into their town or
city clerk's office and when they go to
register to vote Just Right In in
whatever political party they'd like to
to be registered as and they would be
considered under this bill just
Undeclared so they could still vote in
the state primary if they wanted so um
we did discuss this um for members who
are new to the committee we have
discussed this uh minor party question
over the years there is something
different about this bill um compared to
other ballot access bills in that um
a a minor party would not be a major
political party it would be something
that would simply hold its nominating
convention um I believe by the end of
May or June before the filing period to
to turn all their candidates names in uh
but they wouldn't get access to
Congressional and legislative ballots
they would be able to put their
presidential candidate on uh and vice
presidential candidates on and those
candidates you know they won enough
votes would count toward the
4% um although I I'm not sure that
that's ever happened I think maybe Gary
Johnson and Bill weld managed to get
4%
um but the the other thing is a minor
party would only be able to get on for
things like County attorney County
Sheriff County Commissioner and a lot of
uh uh City races if those are
partisan um the thinking behind that is
if a race is going to be partisan
especially a local race
that um that gives a a party the the
chance to highlight how their party is
different dealing with let's say County
attorney um obviously the the
libertarian party and the veterans party
and the pirate party are very different
from the Republican party in terms of
how they handle prosecution or the the
county sheriff's office um um they
address a lot of the their issues very
very differently from from the way
Republicans do or or even uh the green
party might want to uh the green party
wants to highlight how different they
are from the Democrats on a lot of
prosecutorial
issues um so there are a lot of County
and local issues um that that they may
want to highlight so the the
concern that um other members have
brought up that what happens if you have
you know three four five political
parties uh in Congress or for State
Legislature could that just swing the
vote one way or the other and maybe um
issues of tactical voting and strategic
voting and isn't this going to influence
the outcome of uh legislative
races um while these political parties
are gradually building and and getting
themselves set up um I I felt that that
for a minor party that there's a certain
growth phase and I think it makes sense
for them to start at the the county
local level for those partisan races and
get themselves established that way to
see if there's a market or if there's an
interest um for that political party
about 60% of Americans say that they
want a third party in American politics
um but so far none of the third
parties um other than maybe the Reform
Party has has been able to actually kind
of Catch Fire and none of them have been
able to um kind of sustain through their
messaging um enough to kind of snowball
and uh get elected to hire
offices um so there there certainly are
a lot of minor parties out there right
now um apparently there are a couple of
others that are forming right now um
that are getting a little bit of news
coverage and uh I think that the process
the fair process would be for them to
represent thank you madam chair thank
you representative for taking my
question um so you mentioned this
nominating convention that a minor party
would be able to hold in order to
essentially nominate someone how many
people would need to be present at a
nominating Convention of a minor party
um that's a good question um originally
I'd intended to put a minimum number of
people in I
think um the previous version of this
bill was introduced as an amendment just
to another bill a couple of years ago
and I think that there was a number in
there something like a 100 people but I
I
um decided that if they had 500
registered voters uh throughout the
state that that would probably be
sufficient and I I found that it would
be um after talking to people it might
be difficult to try to turn in a paper
that proves how many people attended
that nominating convention obviously if
they they're turning in a dozen
candidates then they had at least a
dozen people present at the at their
convention but if if the committee wants
to set a minimum number of 50 or 100
people or or or some other figure um
then I'm I'm fine with that I'm will
like I say with all my bills I'm willing
to amend it if the if the committee is
interested in um pursuing
this thank you representative Aon I
might just take issue with one just said
when you said if there are 12 people
nominated that means there are at least
12 people present I have at many
meetings where we have nominated people
for things that were not there so I
would hope that political committee
meetings did not do that but um it does
happen so are there any other questions
from people well here in the room we
attending online for representative
anybody I think that a minor party would
have a hard time growing if they uh
tried nominating random people who
weren't even there there
nominate I'm not see any for people
attending to speak on this
bill all right I'm not seeing anybody
thank you very much
coming in this morning I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB
570 um the next item noticed for 10:30
and it is
10 by
rights the prime sponsor of this bill
is that's right I'm sorry me you were
here in the building I'm just not used
hand thank
you thank you madam chair this is my
first time presenting a bill um in this
so great um thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for your time
and opportunity to introduce House Bill
555 for the record my name is Andrew
Balon and I represent Manchester Ward
five this bill is a repeat of a bill
which this committee saw last year it
passed the committee with a broad
bipartisan vote and passed the house on
a Voice vote
like most other bills last year however
it got Co and died in the Senate I'd
like to start by saying that this bill
does not create any rights if you just
read the title of the bill you might
think we're looking to make some major
changes here but I assure you it's much
more boring than that we're not
expanding the right to vote with this
bill at
all earlier today I sent an email to the
committee with a packet of information
which you will find helpful in
evaluating this bill in this packet you
will find a copy of RSA 654 2-a titled
voters confined in Peno
institutions this current law states
that a person behind bars can vote by
absentee ballot the only time an
individual's right to vote is lost is
when they are serving t for a felony
conviction which is addressed in rsa's
654 col 5 and 607a col 2 which I've also
included in the emailed packet so if
you're behind bars a waiting trial or if
you're behind bars because you were
convicted of a misdemeanor and are
serving time you are still legally
eligible to vote in New Hampshire and
this bill as I stated previously doesn't
affect that at all the issue arises when
you actually try to request an absentee
ballot it doesn't affect everybody but
it does affect a significant portion of
the
population I'll use myself and Madam
chair as an example if the two of us got
arrested together and we were
incarcerated at Valley Street jail and
ising and we were incarcerated at Valley
Street jail in Manchester with an
election coming up only one of us would
be able to vote uh I'm sorry only one of
us would be able to fill out the
absentee ballot application and vote in
the election when you look at the
absentee ballot application form section
two lists the reasons that you may be
entitled to vote by absentee ballot and
obviously you must select one of those
reasons well remember that madam shair
and I are in jail together and we're
trying to fill this form out there's an
option that states I plan to be absent
on the day of the election from the city
town or unincorporated place where I am
domiciled that's the most popular option
on this forum and Madam chair you would
be able to use that option because you
are domiciled in gtown and were
currently in jail in Manchester but I
could not use that option because I am
domiciled in Manchester which happens to
be where the jail is and since I'm still
in Manchester I'm certainly not absent
from the city and obviously none of the
other options apply to my situation so
there's a clear problem
here if however I am brave enough to
submit false information on that form
and I actually get a ballot in the mail
it comes with a voter affidavit that I
have to fill out which is on page six of
your emailed packet this form is even
worse because the affidavit requires me
to swear under the penalties of voter
fraud that I will be absent from the
town or city that I'm domiciled in on
Election Day now I have to make a sworn
statement and of course you can see the
Bold text at the bottom there that
indicates that providing a false that
providing false information when voting
is a class A misdemeanor with a maximum
sentence of a year in jail and a $2,000
fine and of course I'm starting to think
that this voting absentee thing isn't
really worth the potential to spend yet
another year in jail so House Bill 555
fixes all of this it's simply adds a
checkbox to the application form and
language to the sworn statement in the
affidavit for individuals who are
incarcerated pre-trial or serving time
for
misdemeanor I did speak with uh deputy
secretary of state scanon about this
bill last year and he said that they
agree that this is an issue and they are
open to adding the language this
concludes my testimony on house build
555 again I thank the committee for your
time and I'm willing to take any
questions you have thank you
representative you before I take
questions could you refresh our memory
as to what the house bill number was
last
year um I don't have any information I
can send it to the comme once I look up
to the elction for session of I think
was in the second year so if you look up
election I I think it might be 1751 if I
remember correctly okay in the second
year um questions for representative
from members of the committee represent
McDonald MK represent question do you
have any idea of how many people might
be affected by this in a given year are
there any statistics on this uh I do not
have any statistics for this however I
would assume that anyone who is
domiciled in Manchester who happens to
be arrested uh or serving time for a
misdemeanor in the Valley Street jail
for example uh would certainly be
affected I I think that number is quite
large questions
MERS any questions from
representa thank you madam chair I'm
proud to say that I have never spent any
time in
jail hypothetically or
otherwise but I enjoyed your little um
thanks well you know things can get idea
so that that was fun um but what would
happen if a person is in a
jail and they request the and I know
they don't spend a lot of time in jail
often times spend just a few days um
what would happen if the ballot is
delivered to the jail and that and at
that point the inmate is gone back to
their
home uh thank you very much for the
question um I do want to point out that
this also applies to people who are
serving time for a MISD demor which
could be up to a year in jail so so for
those people I think that wouldn't be an
issue um for people who are only going
to be in jail for a short time that's
something that they might be aware of
and they may not request the absentee
ballot application for the absentee
ballot if they do get out of jail you
know unexpectedly uh they can uh contact
their city clerk to update their address
and have their absentee ballot uh either
resent or or sent to their their home
address they also have the option uh
anyone who does not or anyone who
requests an absentee ballot who chooses
not to fill out the ballot can show up
at the polling place and um and just
vote like a normal uh individual
would question
represent thank you madam chair uh how
did you become aware of this issue do
you have any real people that you have
spoken to who have brought this to your
attention because it affected them
uh thank you for the question um while I
didn't run into anyone uh who were
specifically affected by this issue I
did run into a number of people during
my campaign who believed that they were
not eligible to vote because they were
felons um and I informed them uh after
doing some research that once you've
served your time as a felon you you do
have your rights restored it was during
that time during that research that I
found that um voters who are
incarcerated can vote absentee and
that's something that I didn't uh I
didn't realize that they could and so I
I wondered how many people actually take
uh take advantage of that and I started
to look into it and I kind of put myself
in their position not physically
obviously um and I looked at the forms
and I realized that I I realized that
that this problem exists and that I
myself if I was arrested would not be
able to uh legally exercise my right to
vote under the circumstances
thank you representative B yes thank you
madam chairman um representative my m i
I do remember the bill from last session
it was actually House Bill 1651 so you
were close when you said
1751 um and I'm looking at page two line
23 of the bill which states as one of
the check off points I am confined in a
penal Institution for a misdemeanor or
while awaiting trial and that's the
exact same language that was used last
session um but I'm looking at it now and
I'm wondering is it conceivable that
someone could be confined in a penal
Institution for a felony and also a
waiting
trial and like this is an either or
situation I'm I'm wondering if there's
going to be word smithing that might
need to be done for
this uh thank you for the question what
what I think you're saying I just want
to clarify are you're saying somebody
who's a accused of a felony who's being
held pre-trial like for for murder or
whatever no actually I'm what I'm saying
is let's say someone has already been
convicted of a felony he is serving time
for a felony but he's also awaiting
trial for some other um reason and where
this is an either or U scenario in line
23 they could say well I'm a waiting
trial therefore I'm entitled to an
absentee
ballot sure thank you very much for the
question um I I do see what you're
saying however I would point out that um
felons do not have the right to vote
regardless of what options may or may
not uh present themselves on this on
this forum um we could say the same
thing if a felon uh was currently in
jail uh in a in a town that they weren't
um domiciled in they could say well I'm
certainly going to be absent so I think
I can I can apply I I'm certainly open
to amending the language to make it more
clear for sure okay thank you very much
that was my only question but it follow
up to that question representative H
um it would appear that the language
fixed for that which might be duplicate
to the law would be or or waiting trial
and I am not a convicted felon but
arguably under that circumstance
wouldn't you add that to every exclusion
and I am not a convicted fell
right I mean because somebody's in jail
doesn't
mean I can be a convicted felon
and be
absent I could be absent from I could
have been convicted of the felony
released you're still in jail for
whatever you did and then if I'm absent
town that I almost have two well I would
still not be able to say I was asking
for B because I a convicted I didn't say
that very well but I think it's a little
example I'm not sure I understand the
question that you're asking me thank you
I'm
sorry terribly so I will ask anybody
else has any questions clarify what I
just
I'm not seeing any so thank you very
much for joining us this morning thank
you very much also signed up to speak
for this bill is K Rand K Rand if you're
in attendance could you raise your hand
thank you very much um welcome to the
committee you and you have been and if
hello committee members um my name is Ka
Randolph and I am submitting testimony
on behalf of the New Hampshire High
School Democrats and the New Hampshire
young Democrats I am testifying in
support of HB 555 because this should
not be a partisan issue past legislation
grants Prisoners the right to vote
therefore the debate around this bill is
not whether or not prisoners should be
allowed to vote but instead if we would
like to make democracy accessible for
all eligible particip an do we want
people's voices to be heard or should we
be complicit in allowing this problem to
exist this bill makes it clear on
absentee ballots that prisoners are
allowed to vote it allows for prisoners
to accurately describe their
circumstances on absentee ballots
addressing an issue of unclear or false
information there are no drawbacks
besides an extra two Clauses having to
be printed and the benefits include
giving eligible citizens a role in
choosing their representatives
supporting our democracy and upholding
their right to vote this concludes my
testimony the benefits of this bill
clearly outweigh the costs I implore you
to vote in support of HB 555 thank you
for your
time thank you very much for joining us
here this
morning is there anybody here who would
like to ask a
question is there anybody online like to
ask
question I'm not seeing any thank you
next signed up to speak for this
is G Pasa from the hu welcome I think
you're with us and ready to go thank you
Madame chairwoman and members of the
committee my name is Jeanie heska I'm
the political director for the American
civil liberties Union of New Hampshire
and I appreciate the opportunity to
testify this morning in support of HB
555 uh which we consider a simple
housekeeping bill um we testified in
support
uh of hb1 1651 last session and so we're
thrilled to be back before you uh this
year as the prime sponsor did a great
job explaining this bill um so I'll just
reiterate um that this bill does not
expand voter eligibility were this bill
to be enacted no individual would be
allowed to vote who is currently unable
to nor would anybody be allowed to vote
absentee who is currently unable to so
it's not about changing eligibility it's
just about clarifying absentee ballot
forms and making sure that people who
are eligible to vote can accurately fill
out absentee ballot forms both the
request form uh and the affidavit form
and I just wanted to note the people who
are detained pre-trial in particular
could be released back into their
Community um any day including shortly
after an election if charges are dropped
or if they're found not guilty and
people jailed on a misdemeanor will
return to their community in the near
future it's in our Collective best
interest to make sure that people who
are released are able to successfully
re-enter their community and part of
that is ensuring that they re they
retain ties to their Community such as
Civic engagement achieved through the
active voting so we really do think it's
important that people who are eligible
to vote are able to do so um and so
again this is just a housekeeping
measure that makes sure that eligible
voters are able to vote at
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you for joining USC to
the elction for this year the person
we've heard from any questions from any
roomes thank you
um Madam and thank you for testifying I
just had a quick which is a question
which is do you by chance know the
average wait time for for bookings in
like place like Valley Street um where a
lot of people get
held uh I I will I'm not sure what the
average time is I will say it has
certainly extended during covid there
are very very few trials happening right
now um and so for people who are being
detained pre-trial their weight is
likely to be significantly longer given
current circumstances
can I follow up M chair follow up
representative you and so in theory yeah
somebody could miss out on an election
um um would you would you agree with
that um yeah oh absolutely um and I and
I would just know um yes people can be
absent during an election in response to
one of the questions previously asked
about that you know if you're detained
for instance in July or August and
you're not sure if you're still going to
be detained in November um you know you
can certainly still request an absentee
ballot form and then if you're released
in time you get to go vote in person um
but if you're not you have the form um
there were a number of people last year
right who requested absentee ballot
forms um and then chose to vote in
person in the end because they were able
to they felt safe enough to do so um so
we we don't think that this impedes
people from voting who may get released
right before an
election thank you thank you
further questions from members of the
committee I'm not seeing any thank you
very much for joining us this morning
with your testimony thank
you uh Miss cynia Walter has also asked
to speak to this bill um she is with us
set Miss Walter if you M we should be
all
set hello I just unmuted thank you um
yes I don't want to repeat what other
folks have said I was um I wasn't clear
on all the nuances of voting rights
within New Hampshire I've just come to
live here in the last year and a half
but I think what the high school
students said and also um is important
about
clarifying um to all in incarcerated
people what um their rights their
abilities are to obtain the absentee
ballot is very important and also we
have to remember these folks are still
paying taxes so we do want to clarify um
their accessibility to to vote because
they're they're still taxpayers thank
any thank you very much
thank you very much Miss Walter also
that Miss Spencer you're with us if you
yes hi hi I'm sorry for the delay thank
you for taking my testimony on this bill
um I think all the points that I was
going to make have been covered so I
just will say that I am fully in support
of this um of this piece of legislation
it's based primarily on conversations
I've had with
people in my door-to-door canvasing who
um who had believed that they like the
sponsor who encountered people who
belied that they were not able to vote
because of their convictions their prior
convictions and seeing the Joy on
people's faces when they realized that
in fact they could participate once
again in Civic
engagement um it just shows me that you
know all of us all walks of life all
lived
experiences
um the right to vote is something that
we we value tremendously and making that
clear to people even in their lowest
moments in time um that we still value
their voice I think is really important
so thank you very much thank you for
joining us anybody have any questions
online I'm not seeing anything we
else to speak on this bill is John Aon
Mr Aon if you're attending
electronically if you raise your hand
that would be
you maybe Mr not join us is there
anybody else present this morning
attending electronically would like to
testify on HB 555 please raise your
you I'm not seeing anybody so I am going
to close the public hearing on house
555 and open the public hearing on
551 551 is relative to a Statewide
database this hearing was noticed for
11 so I am actually looking at the clock
and realizing that I need to wait a few
minutes so we
temporarily a recess and be back at 11
you
e
Madam chairman video and audio has been
representative call Action oh no he's
here good morning everybody election law
committee is back and it is 11 o'clock
and we are scheduled for a hearing on
House Bill 551 relative to the Statewide
voter
database uh this bill requires that the
Statewide centralized voter registration
database we made publicly available in
electronic format for your charge
provided that the Secretary of State may
allow for limited exceptions when a
compelling reason exists to do so um the
prime sponsor of this bill
representative K is with us today and uh
you join us on the panel representative
and if I could just ask that um after
you're you're with us here this morning
if you could go online and log in if you
haven't done so already that you're
speaking on the bill it makes the
welcome representative you're all
set thank you very much thank you to uh
to the the members of the committee for
for hearing HB
551 um my name is representative Jim
kofalt I represent Hillsboro District 4
which uh includes Wilton lineboro
Greenville and
francistown um this uh I I think we
would all agree that transparency is
really foundational to good government
uh for over 50 years our state has
enshrined that principle under RSA 91a
which is uh probably the best known RSA
in uh in the state of New
Hampshire um and there's good reason for
that uh meaningful citizen participation
rests on the Public's ability to access
information um over and over again uh
throughout the past uh Century we have
seen sit situations where waste Fraud
and Abuse were exposed because of
people's ability to access public
information U through right to know or
at the federal level through the Freedom
of Information
Act current law says that uh the
Statewide voter database is private and
confidential um elsewhere it uh it says
otherwise because the the Statewide
voter database in fact is not act
private and conf
confidential um RSA 654 section 31
states that the Statewide voter database
will be made available to political
parties candidates and political
committees for a
fee uh in addition to that anyone who
wants to get their Town's uh voter list
or a towns a city or Town's voter list
uh can do so it's not private
information uh it's it is however
inconvenient um there is generally a fee
involved um it may be provided sometimes
in hard copy uh which usually you know
consumes quite a lot of paper and uh and
time to assemble I would think uh and it
could be provided in electronic
format um so the state has the full list
and
uh representative kofalt we just lost
your
audio not private representative copal
we just lost your audio for a minute so
if you could just back up a bit in your
great there's a great deal
of Representative copal we are not
hearing
connection representative coal are you
hearing can you go on video please
representative kofalt I have no idea if
me these
packs I am not hearing you your
connection is not good you are going in
and
out can you change to
video um changing to video will likely
make the problem worse um if it is
acceptable I will uh I will will switch
to phone audio which I think I can do
fairly quickly would you prefer that
actually just come back on very clearly
so I don't know what was going on there
for a minute okay um I apologize for
that um I'll I'll try to get through
this quickly so um you know I guess the
the bottom line is that um ordinary
citizens who who want access to what is
and should be public information are at
a disadvantage um they don't have the
Deep Pockets to uh to to Fork out $8,000
for the
list um as I said the list is not
private or confidential um the uh the
state does get about $100,000 a year on
average 90% of which goes to cities and
towns but if you uh if you do uh some
very simple math that's an average of
about
$385 per city or town per year um
but putting that aside I would say that
we don't charge for other government
records so it seems
um seems inconsistent that we would
charge for this um I would also uh cite
part one article 8 of the New Hampshire
Constitution which states that uh
government should be open accessible
accountable and responsive to that end
the Public's right of access to
governmental proceedings and Records
shall not be unreasonably
restricted um so for this reason I ask
you to uh to support HB 551 with a
recommendation of to
pass great thank you very much
representative and you and your your
voice came in just fine after
that are
there is there anybody present in the
room representative thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question in your
presentation my question is on the last
line there of the bill line
23 do you have an example of where could
interest thank you representative Mooney
yes um there are some people who have a
restraining order in effect against a
stalker or an an abusive uh
partner and uh have a compelling reason
to not have their information disclosed
on a public list so um so I believe that
there are uh limited cases that would be
um decided at the discretion of the
Secretary of State um where there is a
compelling interest to not reveal uh the
the location uh or address of such
people
thank you thank you representative bers
uh thank you madam chairman uh
representative in your testimony you
were talking about access to the voter
checklist but the bill talks about
providing access to the voter database
the database is a lot more complex than
just the checklist uh it it it's really
the software that is interacting with
the end users the applications the
capturing of data the queries and so on
is is your intent that the public should
have free access to the code that's
behind the data that's being provided on
the
checklist it it is not and I apologize
for my imprecise language I am referring
to the data
itself um and if need be we can clean up
the language to uh to make that clear
today if one is to purchase the
Statewide voter database um I believe
that that is provided in the form of um
a series of Excel or CSV
files um it includes information such as
uh name address voting history and so
forth It's actually
defined uh the the contents of the
6543 uh but the the intention really is
to make
available uh to the public that which is
currently available
uh for for people who can afford to
spend $8,000 on
chairman uh and then as a followup to
that how come you chose not to repeal
the fee structure that appears in 655 31
uh it does say that these checklists
shall be provided to any person
requesting the copies um you know in
your Statute in your bill you're saying
there's no fee but you haven't removed
law should it be um yeah I it I think I
I think it should be yes um and and I
will uh I I will add that I actually
think that there there may be
another provision that needs to be
changed which is uh or or clarified
representative again in the
I'm gonna ask him to call back in if he
has more that he wants to say on to
another attendee and Deputy SC unless
you have a specific question I'll
probably wait till the end to recognize
you
onent
that I I apologize I think my audio went
out it sounds like I'm back now audio
did go out so um why don't you if you
want to call back in if you want to add
to your testimony I'm gonna go on to uh
representative
organ St is going to speak to the bill
and that should give you time to call
back in and we'll go back to you to see
what you want to add at that all right
very good thank you thank you
first time into that the best we
can are us I understand you would like
to speak to House Bill
551 yeah I'm I'm I'm against uh I mean I
think I'm against passing it uh passing
it at this time I the basic idea may
have some Merit um but it's probably not
something that needs to be done uh this
year while we have limited uh capacity
here in the house um
I mostly raised my hand um to correct
something that that I thought I heard
the previous member said which was that
uh government records are should always
be provided free there are a number of
valid cases uh why uh why the government
can charge uh a fee for certain for
certain records and I case of the voter
database that uh there's probably I
think there's probably a good
justification for it um we'll certainly
hear a lot about it um we'll probably
hear a good explanation from secretary
scandin if he chooses to speak but
there's a number of there's a there's a
number of areas uh there's a number of
areas where the government charges for
for uh for for records and as um course
you know better than most of us Madam
chairman because you served on the
Judiciary Committee which deals with the
right to no law and there are so the
U and of course if we gave away all
government records for free that would
lot of functions of government
um such as the registry of deeds but
that's a that's a topic for another bill
and another committee so anyway I I'm I
oppose this bill and I think I thought
there was an assertion made in the
represent kof's testimony that that was
incorrect so I just thought I'd try to
correct it so thank you very much Madam
chair that's about all I have to say
about this so thank you does anybody
have any questions for
thank you madam chair so thanks thank
again
um also with us as I stated as
representative not representative deputy
secretary scamman is with
us I'm here Madam chair thank you um
Madam chair members of the committee I'm
David scanland deputy secretary of state
um here in opposition to the bill as it
is written um I would agree with
represent berson's uh uh interpretation
of what this bill does is um it makes
available the entire database uh of the
registered voters in New Hampshire and
all of the information that goes along
with that um we were required under the
help America vote act that passed um uh
back in 200
uh I think it was 2003 somewhere around
there 2002 to uh along with every other
state in the country that did not
already have one to create a centralized
Statewide voter database and that uh
those databases were required to have
certain information in them which
includes things like not only the
voter's name and address uh but birth
dates um last four digits of social
security numbers driver's license
numbers uh natural calization
information uh along with many other
things um when the state legislature uh
decided to go ahead and create the
database uh it was a matter of policy to
keep uh as much of that private
information of the voters private and so
the law was written the way that uh that
it was written I can tell you that uh
when voters believe that private
information from the datab base has
gotten out uh and we have done a
fantastic job protecting that
information uh they get upset and um you
know we frequently get calls from
voters uh you know saying how did you
get my phone number well um those phone
numbers come from actually other other
lists uh that are put together out there
because the state does not collect that
that type of information whenever we
participated in the interstate cross
check program
we agreed to provide the public part of
the
checklist um to the to the federal
government to uh um you know conduct
that match many voters believing that
their private information uh was at
stake certainly let us know about their
concern in that regard uh even though it
was not being made
available um to get to representative
kofalt Bill and based on his testimony
it sounds to me like he's talking about
the public part of the checklist which
is made available uh to candidates uh
political parties and political
committees the state is the state can
only sell a Statewide list to a
candidate running for office a political
party or a political committee that's
registered in New Hampshire and the
information that we are allowed to
provide is simply the voter's name
uh both their mailing and physical
address uh and their party
affiliation and in the Statewide list we
can provide voter history for the last
two
years any voter any person actually they
don't have to be a voter but any person
can go to the town uh and and obtain the
checklist for that town the public
checklist which contains the information
that I just mentioned um for a fee and I
believe the fee is $25 for the first
1,500 names and then it's 50 cents per
thousand names after
that um the reason that there is a fee
charg is because the supervisors of the
checklist in each town and the board of
registrars in each city are the
individuals that actually maintain the
list they are the only ones that can add
names to a list that can take names off
the list and uh and there is an effort
involved in doing that and so the $25
fee for for obtaining a checklist at the
local level is to help con compensate
them for that uh for that effort the
monies that we collect at the state
level the
$8,000 I think I think it's around
$8,400 now to purchase a Statewide list
is uh also recognizing the effort on the
part of the town because all but $500 of
that amount get sent back to the cities
and towns uh uh at the same level the
town or the city would have collected uh
if if that same list was sold locally so
that's the reason the fiscal note you
see $9,000 of the roughly $100,000 that
we collect in a year is uh is given back
to the cities and towns to help
compensate them for the effort that goes
into maintaining the
list also the Statewide database is
dynamic it changes by the minute it is
uh it's con constantly receiving
information uh information is being
updated by the supervisors of the
checklist again names added names being
removed along with all of the
confidential private information that
goes along with that so um uh you know
it's it's not certainly it's not static
it's certainly when we provide a
checklist it's a snapshot in time and
the checklist that we would provide
today either at the state level or at
the local level
uh will be different tomorrow uh which
will be different from the day after
that
um and uh you know I think I I've made
all of the the points that uh that need
to be made on this it's just uh you know
if we're talking about the public
checklist that is the you know that is
the domain of the legislature and
establishing the policy you know what
fees we should charge you know what's
appropriate um who can obtain it um but
in terms of the private and confidential
data uh that we hold on each individual
voter that is separate and distinct and
we have made a very strong commitment in
the past that we would maintain that
confidentiality and uh we will certainly
continue to fight to do that so with
that Madam chair I would be happy to
answer any questions thank you questions
for Deputy scal from members in the room
representative thank you madam chair
question the prime wants to say that his
intent wasn't to allow that private
information an amendment was done so it
was only the public information would
legislation represent troan I yes if if
the information we're talking about is
uh you already what was already in
currently public I I think that's you
know that's the realm of the legislature
to decide what fees are appropriate to
charge um uh understanding you know the
the the reason for the fees that we
charge that I just
described thank you thank you further
question for members in the room members
attending
electronically any
questions
representative thank you madam
chair are you aware of any states that
are doing what this bill proposes and
let's say it would be amended like uh
representative tone
talked about are you aware of any states
where that uh public data is made
available to everyone who wants
it uh not not specifically represent pom
o'ban I I am aware that each state is
responsible for
determining uh the you know what's going
to be private on their list and what is
not
and and so uh different states have
different laws and some states May be uh
providing the information that we would
consider confidential uh more freely
than uh than we
are thank you other members of the
for I'm not seeing any thank you SC
thank you is there anybody in attendance
who would like to speak to this bill we
are currently in a hearing on House Bill
I see that representative kofalt has
Kofa do you want to add something to
my apologies can you hear me now and
thank you
representative um again I apologize for
the audio issues I am on the phone now I
think it should be good uh I think Mr
scandin has brought up some issues that
um are are are quite important um as
somebody who is very concerned about
privacy issues myself I I would not want
to uh to be putting forth legislation
that compromises private and
confidential information um the the
intent of the bill is in fact to make
the information available uh that is
widely available uh or that is available
currently um to political candidates uh
political action committees and parties
um and I will I will add that there are
a number of states that do make this
information publicly available and
actually have it posted online um
Arkansas Colorado Delaware Florida
Michigan Ohio Oklahoma and Rhode Island
is um may not be a complete list but
that is a list of of states that have uh
this kind of information uh available
online
publicly thank you representative
questions
representative thank you madam chair
could you just repeat those States for
me a little slower Arkansas yes Arkansas
Colorado
Delaware
Ohio
Oklahoma and Rhode
you so Madam chair I would um you know
as after after we're finished here I
would uh I would ask if the committee
would be open to amendments that would
clarify some of the questions that would
that have come up
here representative Kofa thank you for
the question as far as I know the
committee is always open for amendments
um the other issue is representative
poal
um is in regards to the house and this
is a general opening statement for other
members of the committee to chime in um
it's a little out of order but from
normal business but representative
kofalt has asked a question about an
amendment representative kofalt I think
joins the house for the first time so
welcome to the house and welcome to the
election law committee
um we are in the first of two a two-year
session and we all heard representative
foran suggest um that give while there
might be some Merit to this bill given
the session the challenges and I would
point out the year of the session where
the budget is really the priority um
this may or may not be something that
the committee wants to work on to do an
amendment or may not be something the
committee has the ability to work on an
amendment representative kofalt learning
as we all know that we ask OSS for
amendments to statute or to do certain
things and inevitably during public
hearings we find out especially in
election law that there are other
statutes that are impacted that need to
be looked at um so one example of how
the committee might deal with things
that they think are of Merit that maybe
are not going to otherwise be able to be
dealt with this session is that bills
can be retained
um with the report as to what should
happen with them so that further work
can be done on them whereas uh itls will
end the subject matter for this for this
session so um I just put that out there
as a general statement on all the bills
the committee is working
on because I think this is an example of
a bill that had other statutes that were
impacted but not addressed in the
drafting by OLS and it has things that
are going to require I suspect a few
good Minds to work on an amendments so
representative profal I thank you for
bringing the bill
forward and I think the committee is
going to have to have a discussion on
how to proceed on this bill and other
bills but if you have an amendment that
you would like to work on or contact a
Committee Member to work with you on it
um please do so those Representatives do
that r l in regards to legislation that
comes up before a committee that has any
this anybody else want to speak in
regards to either this bill which is
House Bill 551 or but I just spoke about
in regards to the process that is a
us I'm not seeing anything so I'm going
to close the public hearing on 5
1 the next public hearing schedule for
today is House Bill 370 that was
scheduled for public hearing to start at
370 this is relative to the election of
electors of the President and Vice
President of the United States the prime
sponsor is representative bander who
uh thank you madam uh chair and members
of the committee um Madam chair if you
mind me asking was there an amendment
submitted today in regards to this bill
370 um I am not aware of any but I am
not a last minute electronic person I
need to
see m in ahead of time do you have an
amendment representative no ma'am we
received an unapproved Amendment from
Maxon that was fored to the committee
last night okay that would have been
outside of my wheelhouse so apparently
something came in last night from
representative um Abramson and I
apologize representative leer I saw that
you were the prime sponsor and you were
in attendance but I do not have you on
the sign up list did you mean to speak
bill I'm sorry what was the are you
asking me if I mean to speak to this
[Music]
Bill yes on the sign up sheet I just
sort of recognize you so I'm
sorry oh I would hope so that's why I'm
here right all right well just if you
could after the hearing today if you
could go online and sign in on the bill
and that way the record will be complete
electronically that you have spoken on
Bill all right representative blander I
am looking around the committee room
here and I'm not seeing a lot of
enlightened faces as to the amendment so
I am gonna assume that's going to be
true for most of the members
participating electronically so why
don't you tell us about the bill in the
amendment thank you um again thank you
madam chair and the members of the
committee uh my name is representative
Cody bander and I represent Rockingham
District nine from
eping uh I first want to thank everybody
for hearing my testimony today um I know
you guys all have a long day and many
bills to to look over so I appreciate it
and I'll try and keep it as brief as I
possibly can today I'm here to ask you
to support House Bill 370 this bill does
not split up our Electoral College votes
by District or state similar to the main
and ab Braska approach similar to recent
Senate Bill 43 that would have done
exactly that and was unan unanimously
killed by the
senate for years presidents have been
elected by the Electoral College the
Electoral College ensures all areas of
the country have a voice and who is
chosen to lead our great country and has
a built-in way to limit what areas of
the country have their concerns heard on
the campaign
trail that protection is that no one
knows before the election where the
Battleground areas are and putting too
much effort in one area might lead to a
win in one area but losses everywhere
else HB 370 brings that same system into
existence at the state level we as New
Hampshire love our uniqueness we hold
our first in the nation primary even if
Nevada wants to challenge that we are
one of the few states that doesn't have
a lieutenant governor but what we have
even more uniquely as an executive
Council which is why it shouldn't be
surprising that we would come up with
our never tried before method method to
try to bring the benefits of the
Electoral College to our state level
which makes such an attractive state to
come to during presidential elections HB
370 would continue to boost our profile
at the national level it makes us even
more unique than we already are an
argument will be made that this is
political but the data doesn't support
that the Electoral College is so
important that everyone has a voice in
who they elect a candidate who wishes to
become president must obtain a plurality
of votes in a majority of the five
districts this means that a presidential
candidate has to go to Berlin excuse me
barlin colbrook sandwich and most
importantly dickville Notch which holds
the first in the first election instead
of just having to go to Manchester NASA
Portsmith and conquered this bill makes
presidential candidates fight harder for
our votes I ask you to please support
this bill as written not and not the
amend mment and I'm happy to take any
questions this committee may
have thank you representative is there
anybody here in the comme room question
for representative anybody attending
represent um representative aler you
mentioned an amendment could you just
tell us what we're going to see in this
amendment so I don't exactly know what
is entirely in the amendment um but I
know that it would completely rewrite
the method behind and the intent behind
that
thank thank you madam chair and members
of the committee
thank you um also signed up to speak on
this
bill
representa and
representative should be with us and if
you
were you calling on me yes I am thank
you you thank you um Madam chairman and
I uh am a co-sponsor and happy to
support this this uh bill I was
uh briefed a little bit on uh
representative abramson's Amendment um
and it changed
uh the method to splitting up the
electoral votes by uh popular vote and I
think that that is just a step on the
way to um splitting up our electoral
votes by uh uh National popular vote and
I think that uh that that type of Bill
kind of changes the whole or the an
amendment changes the whole uh purpose
of this bill and should be uh presented
on its own in
November and not uh as as an amendment
to this bill and so I think that it I I
value the the Electoral College and I
think that some of the protections that
um that the Electoral College gives the
whole country would be valuable for for
New Hampshire to adopt especially in
light of um concerns ongoing uh about
the security of our elections and so I
think this is one way that we will be
able to uh bootstrap our elections to
make sure that it's harder to game uh
our our elections in New Hampshire so I
thank you and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much for
joining us this morning are there any
questions from members in the
room representative Lane do you have a
question yes um I would interested to
know why doing this by executive council
is more representative of the state than
it's currently being
done thank you for the thank you for the
question so
currently
um there the place there are places in
New Hampshire that have like uh like the
Sea Coast or like the Northern parts of
the state which ha may have different
priorities than other parts of the
states whether it be um fishing or
um Crossing um people trade between uh
Canada etc etc whereas other parts of
the states like nsha may be concerned
more about the relationship to
um Boston and and the tech industry etc
etc and so when
you
uh allow each section of the state
to um kind of have a voice in that
opinion uh instead of being overwhelmed
like the you know the places in the
north their their uh voices may not be
heard as much
because of the voices in new Hamp in
nashille let's say for example are much
louder voices because there's more
people in that place that doesn't
necessarily mean that those people in
the North or in the Sea Coast etc etc
their concerns aren't valid and should
not be considered as a as um a person
who we are choosing to represent new uh
New Hampshire as a whole so thank you
for the
question thank you representative other
members representative Mir I'm sorry I
missed you go ahead please thank you
madam chair um and thank you
representative um I'm curious about
whether your proposal um might make it
possible for um a presidential candidate
to win New Hampshire's electoral votes
without winning um the most votes in the
so thank you for the question yes it
would be possible but they would have to
win in a wide area so electoral Co vote
electoral districts as you know are are
meant to be divided up by uh equally
throughout the state by population but
that doesn't necessarily mean
that um people's choices for who they
would choose would be equally
distributed throughout the the state so
if two3 of the state
chose um if a majority in two thirds of
the state would choose one but uh a
higher percentage in the
uh if yeah if three fifths of the state
chose one but a higher majority in the
leftover two states or the the Le
leftover two districts were uh choose
the opposite it's potentially possible
that those two districts would not uh
would be enough to overwhelm the major
the margin of air uh the margin of
distri the margin of difference in the
other
three uh electoral college or the
Electoral uh executive council districts
I'm
sorry so yes it is theoretically
possible thank you further questions
from
panelists that committee members
representative Wayne yes this is a bit
of a followup to my former question if I
understand you correctly then you are
saying that when you look at um say a
executive Council District too that the
people in Kean and the people on the Sea
Coast have the same interests because
you've is that correct do I understand
that I'm so it it will depend how the um
electoral districts or the executive
council districts are drawn under this
new in the new map whether or not those
two would be in the same electoral uh or
the
same uh executive Council district and
so um my f or you could make an argument
that you could go even smaller and say
you know it at the Town level uh should
be
decided uh and but I think that that
would
um that's fine that an argument to make
I'm not saying that um it has to be
elect elal College districts or not
Electoral College the executive Council
District sorry I'm not saying that it
has to be that I'm just saying that the
uh the benefits of bringing the
electoral college system to New
Hampshire would be uh one that it would
offer the opportunity for different
parts of the states to have their voices
heard and it would also offer um
protections as far as uh security of the
elections in so far that it's harder to
game a system like that where as you
know people talking about oh you know
people voting that from from
uh a temporary housing or um a vacation
rental or something like that whether or
not they were allowed to vote you know
some people from uh vacation towns are
being uh I I think
unfairly um aligned by other other towns
by saying you know whether or not these
people are allowed to vote in their town
and so if they weren't allow if
it
was um in a different section and it
didn't
in representative we're going to move on
to any other thank you
representative
Esa I I wav my question I I apologize
but I thank you for your time Mr chair I
wave my question thank
you any other questions from
panelists that would be committee
members in the
room
elic I'm not seeing
any thank you representative for your
testimony here this morning
next person who has signed up to speak
on this bill is Linda Bundy if Miss
Bundy is present could you please raise
her hand and we will bring you
up thank you very
much maybe I should be a teacher I'm
finally getting us raise your hand s
Miss Monday if you unmute yourself you
will be with us to testify on HB 370
welcome
thank you madam chair and good morning
to you and members of the election law
committee for the record my name is
Linda Bundy and I'm a voter from antrum
I am speaking in opposition to HB
370 currently all presidential electors
are awarded to the presidential
candidate who wins a plurality of the
popular vote in our state if HB 370 is
enacted and electors of the president
and Vice President of the United States
are designated by the party that
receives a plurality of votes in a
plurality of executive council districts
it is conceivable that the presidential
electors could be awarded to a candidate
who did not win a plurality of the
popular vote while still winning a
plurality of the executive council
districts all votes would not carry the
same weight as demonstrated in
2011 voting districts can be unfairly
manipulated during the redistricting
process to take advantage of the system
a Jerry Mander like executive Council
District 2 could unfairly deprive voters
of the power of their vote that's
neither the New Hampshire nor the
American way additionally if there were
an absence of a plurality in the
executive council districts and the New
Hampshire Senate awarded the electors
the result could be even further removed
from the wishes of the voters for these
reasons I oppose HB 370 I believe that
one person one vote is what matters in
determining which candidates are awarded
New Hampshire's electoral votes thank
you for your
time testifying is there anybody here in
the room or anybody attending
electronically who has any questions
buing
[Music]
I'm not seeing any thank you very
much also signed up to speak on this
bill it is representative
Corgan
election representative you should be
representative for you're all set thank
you yes I I even add as a panelist here
you can see me so I actually put on a
tie today so that's um turn on I'm not
getting a
tie okay well maybe I need any I do have
one on you so represent Timothy Horgan I
represent uh oh here we go I represent
stford County district 6 this is the
towns of Durham and Madbury so that's in
the Sea Coast I have lived in grafting
County in the past which is the North
country and believe me the presidential
candid campaigns paid plenty of
attention to us up there I have lived at
various times in past in large states
and uh well they they're as American as
anyone else I've lived in New York and
California but um anyway the timing of
this bill is I think could not be worse
I mean it was probably filed uh you know
back in November long before the events
of January 6 20221 when a mob invaded
the capital during the official count of
the 2020 electoral vote so that and of
course that Invasion turned what should
have been a routine ceremony honoring
the let's speak to the bill all right
thank you so um we in New Hampshire we
were fortunate we had an unambiguous
presidential election here in the
granted State uh Biden and Harris won a
free Fair well-run election by
comfortable margin 48% of hire's Voters
were disappointed by the result but 100%
of those voters confident that the vote
count was correct um and the uh
electoral college is a ancient but
controversial institution because
amongst other problems it's possible for
one presidential candidate to win the
popular vote without winning the
presidency um this happened most
recently in 2016 and uh as some Britten
testimony I go on about what happened
over the last four years let's just say
it was not all good um and uh the
previous president um he was not
reelected in November so not being
reelected is pretty a normal occurrence
which happened to many other presidents
who serve during bad times including
some
me anyway okay um it's bad enough that a
president can win the electoral college
without winning popular vote Nationwide
and actually this
year this year what happened Nationwide
it should have been a you know it was a
pretty much of a clear-cut uh the result
was pretty clear clut Nationwide I mean
their election was not entirely without
problems but like you know it's pretty
obvious who wanted who lost and uh
decide that one got a comfortable
majority of the Electoral College and
the actually got and the popular vote
but anyway but it's bad this could but
it's even worse this could happen here
Statewide our electoral votes could go
to um a candidate who didn't win the
Statewide uh
popular vote because it's certainly in
fact this probably might have happened
in 2020 because we had uh we had w we
one Electoral College District that was
you know heavily skewed heavily skewed
Democratic and um so and but there's
four El Republican electoral counselors
and one Democrat which uh that's how it
goes so um you know it allows president
take to get our states for electoral
votes without a majority of the
Statewide Vote or even a plurality
depending on how the votes are
distributed between the five uh rather
arbitrarily drawn executive council
districts and for good measure if no
take a wins the plurality of the five
districts I mean which that's virtually
impossible U especially if we if the
two- party system stays in place but um
the Tai vote is broken not by the
Statewide vote totals um but by the
state senate and that's like uh makes me
a little aggravated to see that even
though it could almost never happen we
did have several state legislators uh in
other states per pressure to like uh IGN
you
know I'm rning behind schedule so I'm
going to ask you to stick okay I'm
almost I'm almost done here uh so I so I
I that's an objectionable provision that
the state senate would choose the
electors even if it's in a situation
that is virtually impossible U the New
Hampshire Senate is by the way it's of
course the other problem is which state
senate is going to elect the ctors if
there is you know a
deadlock amongst the executive councils
like is it the is it the previous Senate
that's voted out of office in November
or is it the incoming Senate and they
only take office a few days before the
electors are supposed to meet to cast
their votes so that's that's uh
problematic right there like um so
that's U basically is everybody
including one of the co-sponsors agree
this is a bad Bill and it should be
killed but just on a you know Ty the
facts unworkable it's it's a
fundamentally bad and unfair idea so I
find it um somewhat repugnant to our
small D democratic ideals here in the
Hampshire so that's uh that's that's a
so is there any in the room or
electronically that has a question for
representative
for I'm not seeing any thank you for
joining us and thank you for your time
oh well thank oh well thank you thanks M
um is there anybody else present who
wishes to speak to this bill um Cynthia
Walter I see that you have your hand up
um I'm welcome to speak to this bill I
am going to ask that you take a few
minutes because I am running behind and
I have a number of people signed up for
the next bill that will be our last bill
of the morning welcome Miss Walter
welcome back to the
um thank you um in the interest of time
I will submit my comments in writing
thank you um could you just tell us if
you're in support or I'm sorry I'm
strongly opposed to this bill and I'll
out line the U um mathematics behind it
and also the uh the the that there's
other ways to accomplish the goals of
the persons who um promoted the bill in
the first place there's there's Better
Math that we can do thank you
thank
you and I also have um other people to
speak to this bill Miss benser joins us
would like
to you should be with us if you we are
all set hi thank you um um Madam chair
for taking my testimony I I hadn't
intended to speak but I do oppose this
bill
um what made me want to speak though
were the comments from representative
yoka one of the sponsors who talked
about um one of the reasons he put this
bill forward was concerns about security
and making it harder to gain the system
and I find it very upsetting when these
sorts of comments get put forth with
no no facts backing them up no
Foundation um they're very serious uh
accusations against our election system
we were shown to have a a very um good
election here in New Hampshire uh we can
be proud of our election integrity and I
just could not let such claims go
unanswered so with that I'll I'll end my
testimony but thank you very much thank
you
any questions from Miss Spencer from
committee members in the room or
attending
electronically I'm not seeing any is
there anybody else who wishes to speak
to house bille
370 I'm not seeing anybody so I'm GNA
close the the hearing on house 370 and
I'm going to open the next public
hearing the next public hearing is on
was7
h42 us somebody is on on mute
representative wol welcome are you here
to thank you madam chairman and thank
you members of the committee
of all that the legislature will do in
this session one of the most important
is to establish new electoral District
Maps following the 2020 census whenever
that is completed this bill which has
bipartisan support requires that the
committee appointed to consider
redistricting shall have an open and
transparent process with specific
defined goals and objectives and
criteria these shall be such that it is
clear to all what the process shall
be HB
428 specifies the redistricting process
be made accessible to the public in
several
ways first it requires the committee to
Define its priorities and attentions
intentions for map drawing the committee
shall solicit input from local and
County election officials to assist it
in its work upon releasing a preliminary
plan this legislation requires a public
Hearing in each County with at least 20
days notice of such
hearing and any preliminary plan shall
be released to the public at least 30
days before the first hearing on the
final plan it further requires map
drafts to be posted on some public
access
website on page two the bill states that
the final report shall include a summary
of all public input all Draft plans and
data considered and used by the
committee and it must State the plan's
adherence to its original criteria for
drawing the
districts any final plan including Maps
should must be noticed at least s days
prior to holding a
hearing the public has become far more
aware of the importance of redistricting
in the past 10 years as a legislature
gets ready to do its work to draw a new
map
voters of both parties and Undeclared
voters are demanding transparency and
fairness this bill still leaves the
process in the hands of the legislature
and that's an important thing to note by
making this process transparent and
welcoming of public input the voters of
all parties will have greater confidence
in the fairness of the final plan I hope
that we can continue to have bipartisan
support for this transparency Bill thank
you thank you I apologize Madam chairman
today you
still say anything thank you for joining
us so questions from committee members
for representative wal from committee
members in
fending
electronically I'm not seeing any
sentive W I actually have a couple
questions
um I would presume that in regards to
public hearings the presumption is that
you is there your intent would be for as
many members of as possible for any such
committee to be present at public
hearings does that make
sense that does but uh as I have learned
and come out of the dinosaur age in the
last three or four months I've learned
of the ability to use electronic um
communication such as the zoom
conference that we're on right now so I
don't think they physically have to be
present all right and I have um a
question in regards to the effective
date um the ACT would take effect 60
days after its
passage um and you know what the time
frame is for bills working their way
through this session is is it your
intent that this would apply to a
redistricting commission that might be
established before it is pass this
[Music]
legislation yes I would think that I
would like this new redistricting
processes thank you other questions from
committee
members thank you very much for joining
us sorry represent P has a question
representative thank you mad chairman
thank you for tting the question uh
should we look for a fiscal note to be
point representa is there a cost
associated with this should there have
um but uh if we feel that it should be
Services thank you any questions for
committee
members I'm not seeing any so thank you
representative for joining us also
lalist and uh I believe you should be
all set to testify good
morning you mute we're all set you w
second good good morning um Madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
Henry Clement toich and I'm testifying
today on behalf of the American civil
liberties Union um in the interest of
full disclosure and transparency I am a
registered lobbyist for uh that
organization so um we support HB
428 um for the following reasons I think
it um would be our preference uh as a
civil rights organization that districts
in New Hampshire following the desial
census be um apportioned by an
independent redistricting commission but
failing that uh this bill is a good bill
in the promotes public transparency and
confidence by um establishing processes
so that the public can be confident that
the maps that are drawn are being drawn
out in public New Hampshire is one of
the few states in the country that has
constitutionalized a right of public
access to government records in part one
article eight of our Constitution and
has one of the stronger public records
laws uh in any of the states in RSA
91a and those laws combined with the
legislator's practice of holding a
public hearing on every single Bill
demonstrate to the citizens of New
Hampshire uh that we take governmental
transparency seriously here and uh this
bill would do the same thing for the
apportionment process by recognizing
that it's a very significant piece of
legislation that's going to affect the
entire State and many many community
ities and would um for example require
public hearings be held in every County
and would require uh any committee
tasked with drawing the apportionment
plans to maintain a website and post uh
the information that they have there and
that way at at beginning middle and end
of the apportionment process voters in
New Hampshire and your constituents can
look at the process and have confidence
in why the maps were drawn the way that
they were and can come to informed
conclusions about whether they like that
legislation or not um so we believe that
it would be that this bill would be a
very important step towards uh fostering
public confidence in the apportionment
process um and so we urge the committee
to vote a to pass and I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you for joining us today
any questions from committee members in
electronically I do have a question
actually um one of the requirements of
the bill is to have a hearing in every
Cil yeah it was pointed out by the prime
sponsor in the language of the bill that
remote participation is to be
allowed so if indeed remote
participation is the latest and greatest
and we're allowing it why should this
commission have to actually go to Every
County so I think uh thank you for the
question I think the um the intent of
holding a hearing in every county is to
is to bring an opportunity for people to
testify uh before this apportionment
committee and to meet those those
impacted by the bills where they are and
that you know is why in the past for
example committees uh addressing the
budget have held hearings outside of
conquer um in light of the covid-19
pandemic we wouldn't oppose an amendment
that would allow some of those hearings
to be done
remotely um but I think the I think the
intent or the purpose behind it would be
um to really the goal would be to
promote as much access by the public to
these meetings as possible and if that
means in the current climate
doing it by Zoom I think that's okay but
if it means going forward when the
pandemic ends fingers crossed um doing
it in person in the various counties I
think that makes sense
committee sorry I just I got what I I
gota follow so then if the point is to
go outad and meet people like County
right because Counties have
different interest and that's one of the
things that we do generally in the
districting is sort of try to stick to
county lines um does that mean at public
hearings we restrict input to people
from that county that we having the
public
hearing I don't I don't know why um that
would be
necessary candidly um I mean I suppose
you could limit testimony that each
person can only testify at one public
hearing um but uh you know there may be
I live in Portsmith it may be that uh
the straford county meeting is actually
closer to me for whatever reason than
the Rockingham County would be so I
don't know why you would need to
restrict it that way all right thank you
I won't take up any more times with my
NeverEnding questions about how you
should be conducting meetings for
members all right I'm not seeing any
thank you very much for joining us this
morning than signed up to speak this
morning on this bill
um is Bill
Hatcher Mr
Hatcher I have promoted you to a
panelist and you have appeared if you
unmute yourself I think we're all set to
hear from you good morning good
afternoon good morning let me just see
camera there we go thank you madam chair
my name is Phil Hatcher and I'm a
resident of
Dober I'm testifying today to urge you
to support HB
428 on February 20 on February 10th
Gober city council passed a resolution
calling for the redistricting process to
be transparent and open in public to the
public input at all stages I believe
this is one piece of evidence that there
is Broad support for this bipartisan
Bill across the state one of our
counselors did vote against the
resolution however although he orted the
sentiment of the resolution he was
concerned about the council getting
drawn into a partisan political fights
but this makes me wonder how can calling
for open and transparent redistricting
be part of a partisan
fight do some people think that the only
way they can attain their political
goals is through a closed process with
no public
input why should redistricting be any
different than the consideration of
bills to create new laws where there are
mandatory public hearings such as this
one public trust in government is is
severely eroded because people believe
that politicians too often act upon
their own self-interests rather than in
the public interest Jerry mandering in
particular is disliked for this reason
by people of all political
Persuasions and remember that supporters
of both parties are hurt when one party
draws District boundaries for political
gain consider New Hampshire's notorious
second executive Council District in
which Democrats were packed to improve
Republican chances in the other
districts Republican voters in the
second district had their voices taken
away which in particular could be
problematic when executive Council
decisions impact their local towns and
cities in ways not fully understood by
the counselors and other
districts please vote ought to pass an
hp42 28 please vote for open and
transparent redistricting and please
take one small step towards rebuilding
trust in government thank you very much
thank you for your testimony this
P I'm not seeing any thank you very much
for being with us this morning also
signed up to speak on this bill is
Cynthia Walter uh Cynthia if you're here
could you raise your hand I just don't
Cynthia you should you're with us again
428 yes I'm here can you hear me now can
okay great so again I'm Cynthia Walter
I'm a retired uh science Professor
biologist and I'm I teach statistics all
the time and so I strongly recommend um
passing this bill because it it provides
Fair uh um opportunities for citizens to
understand the districts I've um worked
on campaigns ever for the last uh 40
years of my life just as a volunteer and
so I understand how important it is for
people to know where these boundaries
are and how those boundaries got to be
where they are so I hardly endorsed the
bill I just I'm the one who suggested a
slight modification in the bill
associated with the um collection of
information
um from the um um Municipal uh electoral
officials and their testimony needs to
be public and we also need more publicly
available information to the public on
the results of the census
information in other words we can't
understand why the maps might be drawn
differently coming forward than than
they were in the past if we if all the
people don't have all the information in
a fair open um environment um and so
it's important I think to pass this bill
and have those exchanges but we have to
give everybody the information to make
the exchanges
worthwhile um for and just a quick
example um of why we need to make the
Census Data
available to both the um electoral
officials in a form of a questionnaire
that they would then address to to make
comments about changes in demographics
and changes in communities of interest
and so on it's important for them to see
it but I would like also for that
information on the Census Data to become
available to the public as well then
people can not just guess at how their
neighborhoods and communities have
changed um but they can actually see it
represented in some physically clear and
and open to the public um plain language
descriptions um I know how to get into
to census track data but I'm I've got a
doctorate you know that's not fair for
me to look at that data whereas other
people can't look at that data we need
to have um that be part of this bill as
well and what I suggested a little bit
was a way to do that so I think it's a
great Bill the way it is um it can even
be strengthened and and move forward in
that direction thank
you thank you Miss W for joining us on
this so question for members of the
electronically I'm not seeing any other
so miss Walter just for clarification
for my notes so you're speaking of uh
possible information exchange or release
that is not currently in the bill that
you have suggested an amendment to
someone
for yes if I can hear you correctly I'm
sorry my hearing is not very good um yes
i u sent an an email letter to every
member of the committee suggesting a
slight modification in the first section
um Roman numeral four um of the bill I
think it's the first section um and that
would be an idea but again I you guys
you folks know a whole lot more than I
do about these matters I'm only a
biologist
um close to atici too so I just wanted
to highlight that so if members of the
committee are looking at that that
they're aware that that's out there
because it's not in the bill in front of
us are there any further questions for
Miss
wther I'm not seeing any thank you very
much for joining us on this bill also
signed up to speak on this bill this
morning is Louise Spencer Lise I have
you are with us if you unmute I think we
will be all set
good morning and thank you again Madame
chair for taking my testimony thank you
to the committee uh for the record my
name is Louise Spencer I live in conquer
and um I am here in support of HB
428 um I've spent quite a bit of time
over the last few years working on
trying to come up with a fair
redistricting process and um was am
supportive of the idea of an independent
redistricting
Mission however I know that despite
bipartisan support for that approach
there remain members who have concerns
about the
constitutionality of such an approach
none of those concerns apply to this
bill and I believe this bill goes a long
way in accomplishing many important
goals in terms of
transparency fairness and citizen
engagement and participation
um and for that reason I strongly
support it um I think we live in a time
where we are divided um along political
lines in ways that that we haven't seen
perhaps in
Generations um and that part of the way
we get back to a more um integrated and
um
and
approachable Civic um environment is by
creating some guard rails that help
everyone build trust in our systems and
I think this bill creates a lot of great
guard rails for the redistricting
process and one that will allow people
across the political Spectrum to buy
into and come away then feeling that uh
there was fairness and transparency so
for those reasons I would strongly
encourage you to support this bill um
and to move it out of committee in a
bipartisan way to show your commitment
um as this committee so often has done
in the past to bipartisan solutions to
to problems and issues so thank you very
much thank you for testify on this bill
with us this afternoon is there any
member of the committee either present
or electronically who has a question for
ven I'm not seeing any so thank you for
being here than
you up to speak this morning is Miss
suan Richmond Miss Richmond you are with
us if you could unmute I think we'll be
all
set uh thank you madam chair and and
thank you very much to the committee for
accepting my testimony I'm speaking in
support of House Bill
428 I live in Durham and on January 11th
of this year the Town Council of Durham
supported 9 to zero a resolution for
nonpartisan Fair
redistricting uh with transparency I
think at the time we were hoping it
would be a committee but I'm sure In The
Same Spirit uh house built 428 addresses
many of the same
concerns uh Governor sonunu repeated in
since New Hampshire doesn't have a
history of Jerry mandering but that is
not true the New Hampshire Constitution
part two article 11 states when the
population of any town or Ward according
to the last federal census is within a
reasonable deviation from the ideal
population for one or more
representative seats the town or Ward
shall have its own District of one or
more representative seats and informing
the districts the boundaries of towns ws
and unincorporated places shall be
preserved and
contiguous so at our last redistricting
in
2011 every municipality with a
population of
3,290 or more was entitled to its own
exclusive
representative but 62 out of the 152
towns and Wards in New Hampshire that
qualified for their own representatives
were denied their own seat in the house
that's
40.8% more than a third of New
Hampshire's towns and Wards were
disenfranchised of having a full voice
that would be gerrymandering and further
that L three districting did break up
cities towns and Wards to create
representative districts without
contiguous borders so despite what the
governor has said it's not true that we
do not Jerry Mander in New Hampshire and
it's further not enough just to say well
I trust the legislature they will do
what's right because the temptation to
draw redistricting lines that will
protect your position or benefit your
party has got to be overwhelming you
don't ask the fox to watch the hen house
unless you plan to keep careful watch on
the fox so in our last regist excuse me
in 2011 Maps were drawn in secret and
the software being used is still secret
today and the public didn't get to see
the maps until the day before they were
voted on members of the legislature made
their requisite visits to every County
to discuss redistricting but they had no
Maps so that is the context in which we
are asking for transparency now h428
would not deprive the legislature of its
responsibility to draw new maps it just
provides communities with their right to
view the maps to provide input and you
our Representatives can Ure the people
you represent they will have fair and
equal representation transparency is not
a threat when the work's done fairly HP
428 would give us government that
everyone could trust and believe in so
thank you so much for hearing me out and
uh I hope you will support
428 thank you Miss Richmond for your
testimony here this morning does anybody
have any questions for Miss
Richmond anybody online ra
hand ically I'm not seeing any so thank
you very much for joining
us also signed up to speak on this this
morning is lelli on behalf of
the voters good morning good afternoon
Miss tendell if you want mute you are
with
us thank you very much uh representative
Griffin for allowing me to speak I'm Liz
tentarelli I'm president of the League
of Women Voters of New Hampshire I'm
speaking to today in strong support of
this transparency bill um as Henry
Clement toich pointed out uh
transparency is inherent in our state
constitution and the holding hearings on
bills I I don't know Pam if you're on
whether it's us or her um frankly now
we're all back you froze up I think it
might have been our
system okay I will back up a bit I'll
identify myself again as Liz
tentarelli I'm president of the League
of Women Voters of New Hampshire a
nonpartisan organization I am not a
lobbyist I am a volunteer and I'm
speaking in support of House Bill
428 because it encourages the very kind
of
transparency that this committee and
this legislature should be so proud of
the fact that you're holding these
meetings remotely so that we the public
can attend and
participate shows your commitment to
that and I ask that you continue that
commitment by supporting this
bill I sent you some very detailed
written
testimony that explains why that trans
how that transparency did not happen in
2011 many people in the public many
voters were angered by that uh many
legislators were frustrated by that lack
of
transparency we will do better in 2021
and I'm confident of that because the
public is now demanding that involvement
so posting plans maps and public comment
on a website as this bill uh describes
as one part of it those meetings in the
10 counties are very much a part of the
tradition in 2011 they were held but
there was nothing there to talk about
there was no real input or discussion
about Maps because nothing was shown
that shouldn't happen this year uh
representative Griffin you asked whether
there should be a fiscal note attached
to this I believe there will be a fiscal
note that will have to be attached to
the bill that sets up the Committees
which you have not heard yet and so this
would be part of the committee's
operating budget if you will um to
include the the the website the um
noticing of public hearings and so on um
so on on that ground and the fact that
the public really wants to continue in a
spirit of
transparency so that we can have trust
again in the districts and in our
government I strongly urge you to
support this bill if there are any
questions about my written testimony I'd
be glad to answer those via email or
here in person thank you for this
opportunity thank you for coming and
joining us this afternoon does anybody
in the committee room or MERS
electronically have any questions for
Miss
T I'm not seeing any we did get your
email so thank you for joining us and
submitting your testimony on this matter
thank you also signed to speak on this
welcome good afternoon members of the
committee um for the record my name is
aivia zinc and I'm the executive
director of open democracy action um
we're a nonpartisan nonprofit based here
in conquered um that works on fixing our
democracy I'm here to speak in favor of
house bill um for TW
28 um on Friday February 12th the Census
Bureau announced a timeline for
releasing um this redistricting data to
the states of September 30th of this
year um also the National Conference on
State Legislature um released an article
five ways to handle the census delay and
I think that this piece of legislation
page two line 11 through 13 um requiring
the committee to um establish the
criteria of how they're going to draw
the districts um is a great idea and
also gives them time to do that before
the Census Data is Al
allowed I hope that their um data that
they you or the criteria that they
publish is that the districts shall
comply with the New Hampshire
Constitution and the US Constitution and
the Voting Rights Act of
1965 um the districts are based on on
inh inhabitants they're
contiguous um that no racial minorities
are are um District did in any form um
that we respect the integrities of our
communities of interest um and don't
divide any towns or Wards in those towns
um as others have spoke of um
the last redistricting process 10 years
ago did not respect New Hampshire's
Constitution um 62 towns were denied
their uh
representation um I am also um footnoted
um house Journal um from 10 years ago um
that cites that the maps were only given
to the public 24 hours notice the last
time and I urge that we can do better
this round and how SP
um
428 really does provide
transparency and a process where voters
will know that this is a two-way
conversation between voters and their
elected
officials this bipartisan Bill calls for
fairness in the
process I think you've you can identify
comments that were made um and on other
actions that really citizens want a f
Fair nonpartisan and transparent process
and this is an opportunity for us to not
just take those words but also put them
into action by by passing this law so
ahead of the
2020 2021 census um please respect
voters Wills for an honest and fair
process and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
this morning does anybody have any
questions for Miss
questions from Members either present in
electronically I'm not seeing any
questions so thank you very much for
joining us also signed up to speak on
this bill is John
Aon Mr Aston I have not seen you the
attendee list if you're with us here
this morning you
please raise your hand
or if you're calling in I think it's
star six but I'm not seeing any
telephonic
participants not seeing Mr Aon is there
anyone else present in this hearing on
HB 428 who would like to
speak please raise their
hand I not seeing
anybody
MERS all right I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 42 eight I
want to thank everybody for their
attention this morning we are now going
to recess for lunch we will reconvene at
1:30 to exact bills so have a nice lunch
houres to do
that
for
e
very odd walking around this building go
by we are unmuted and video is on by
committee GRS now and you hear a meeting
going on it sounds as clear as day the
soul need to be reminded all right we
are here at 1:30 sorry my computer says
1:32 for notice executive session on
certain bills before we get going um I
want to let committee members know a a
little bit about
scheduling we are scheduled for two
session days next
week um I have opted not to schedule
election law on Friday next week given
that we will be doing business for two
pretty much two pretty much full days
though other committees are meeting if I
hear committee members begging to meet
on Friday there I have just been
informed this room is open no one has
taken it and I will be happy to schedule
it on Friday um however my plan would be
for the first two weeks in March I have
asked for three
days um
so uh that is the plan and it will be I
have asked for a Wednesdays or
Friday so as soon as I have those days I
will send an email out that those are
the days I will be scheduling public
hearings on and probably another
executive session I expect those days to
be long because my intent is to schedule
the acente ballot bills there are a
number of them and I am expecting the
public hearings on those bills alone to
be at least a
day and I might schedu them for more
than a day so that's the sort of status
of
the scheduling for the next few weeks
representative quy thank you m so
scheduled a total of three days for
those two weeks that's my plan we have
until I think the 18th to finish our
voting I'm not quite sure I might be off
a week it's in the
calendar have basically march to finish
up the bill so that's my my goal but
these public hearings I think we can get
the public hearings on the remaining
bills done in three days we have 18
bills
left that is the status anybody else
have any
questions yeah Madam chair could you
repeat the days next week well no next
week we just we have house session on
Wednesday and Thursday okay since we
meet on Friday normally I said we will
not meet on Friday since we've already
everybody's already spending two days
but over the next two weeks one week
will have two
days all right but if you want to meet
on Friday apparently this room is
available even and I could have a
meeting about a couple of bills or most
people were happy when I said today not
to come in for the committee Mee but I
think we can get it done without three
days coming in on Friday next
week all right so for notice this
afternoon the first bill we have noticed
for executive session today is
sb2 I am going to continue the executive
session on
sb2 I had a question that I
uh sent over to the Secretary of State's
office between the public hearing and
today requesting information on how many
communities had actually
rescheduled and when they were
rescheduling for and they've been pretty
busy they haven't been able to get back
to me and uh since the towns are able to
continue to operate under the emergency
order 83 I think um
I think we can move on from sb2 it's not
technically an early
Bill the next bill that we have
scheduled for executive session is CAC
R4 in regards to
redistricting this is u a bill that
provides that an independent districting
commission shall be established to draw
braries for state and federal Offices
this is a cacr and not a house bill is
there a motion on this representative
brow Madam chair I moved cacr 4 in
expedient to legislate this propos is
there a second to the representative's
motion that's been moved and second it
thank you all right would you like to
speak to your yes I would M thank you
this proposed Constitutional Amendment
would independent districting commission
the stated reason for this amendment is
that it would make redistricting the
redistricting process
nonpartisan however the appointment of a
committee established for this purpose
would itself be a partisan process which
would in reality be controlled by the
majority party further this proposed
amendment does not address how the
commission would be appointed so even
establishing rules for the makeup of the
commission and for how it would be
appointed would be partisan New
Hampshire has the large legislative body
in the United States this makes our
legislature the most representative
group Commission of the people if you
will to perform this constitutional
responsibility
redistricting by a commission appointed
by elected leaders of respective
political parties further insulates
redistricting from the will of New
Hampshire voters I urge that this task
continue to be done as charged in our
Constitution and not be delegated to an
appointed commission please support the
motion of I for cacf
4 thank you does anybody else want to
anybody I'm not seeing
call the motion on the floor is to itl
there is a hand up sorry there is a hand
Lane I don't I don't know if this is the
appropriate time to ask the question um
but my understanding is that one of the
major reasons for the opposition to the
bill is that this the Constitution does
not does not specifically provide that
we can delegate that so this would so I
guess my question is
would if we can't do it by
Constitutional Amendment then how do we
do
it like sure if you want to answer that
representative BR go ahead thank you for
your question um I do not believe there
should be a commission because I believe
that uh a commission very quickly will
become fully as partisan or more
partisan than than the current process
and I believe that since we have the
largest legislative body in the nation
especially since that we already have a
commission that is appointed by the
people to do this process so I don't
believe we should have a commission that
is legislatively established or that is
approved by a change in the
Constitution may I have a followup
please ative
goe um so you you're saying that the the
existing committee is appointed by the
voters my understanding is that the
existing that the new committee or how
it's done I've never gone through this
process as a
legislator is appointed in fact by the
parties not by the people is my
understanding
correct the r it's it's appointed by the
majority and it's the speaker committee
so I when you say parties I don't know
what you mean
representatively so responding to his
comment that the existing committee
process was done by the people my
understanding is exactly as you said it
which I would say is not by the people
so I just want to make sure I
understood how it's done because I've
never been involved in
it it's my understand
that persons that will serve on the
committee will be elected
representatives and I understand your
point as to the constitutionality that
this bill is intended to remedy that
complaint um and I think representative
growan if I'm paraphrasing correctly
your point is we already have all the
representatives here we don't need
further
delineations any other comment I I will
just say I've spent a lot of time
looking at other States and I have found
that in some other states where they do
this in their constitution sort of
interesting that they do it for example
the congressional district and that's
all that's in their constitution that
they leave the other
districts um for the legislature to do
so that's sort of an interesting thing
and some of the states that do have it
in their constitution they do it for
specific
places is there any other discussion on
this
any all right I'm not seeing any so I'm
is representative McDonald
yes representative pron O'Brien yes
representative Sween yes representative
Hayward yes representative Mooney yes
representative toosan yes representative
Barry yes representative gr yes
representative qua
yes
yes representative Cody no
representative Cody could you come on
screen for just a second for me please
thank you very much and it's nice to
actually see you by the
well thank you madam chair same
here Ward
no representative Brer on
no
represent
no representative HR no representative
Lane
frus representative is still with
meeting representative HL
Yad
[Music]
will should to8 11 the the itl on cacr
for passes 11
to8 the next vote uh scheduled for this
afternoon is
hb77 requiring town and city clerk to
provide daily notifications to the
Secretary of State um there was an
amendment that we received here in the
room over lunch I understand it should
have been emails to the committee but I
am operating from two different phones
neither one of which I can operate
completely successfully so I can't swear
to that um
repres And hb77 in regards to the
notification um and filings
is
Representatives Barry do you have a
motion that you'd like to put on the
floor yes Madam chairman I make a motion
to amend uh hb77 with the amendment I
presented to the
committee and that would be
042 yes ma'am 0402 H is there a second
I'll
second all right let me ask do people
have if who have online access attending
remotely do you
have that we just talked
about no I don't believe I don't believe
no so did that get email to the
committee I will send that right now
Madam chair I thought it had been sent
that just to stay in order we're just
going to take a little pause and give
everybody a chance to take a look at
this because I didn't look at it during
lunch either let me know when it's been
right I just sent it to everybody on the
committee because that's easiest so it
should be
arriving
okay
back I've had a thank you I'm glad to be
back all right we have just had
everybody emailed an amendment to to
House Bill 77 so I don't know if you're
able to also ask access email while
you're online but it was just emailed by
Pam smling to all the committee members
Deputy scalan is sitting there wondering
at I'm sorry madam chair I I just joined
in after I jumped over from the senate
election law executive session so I'm I
just barely arrived I I don't know
what's going
on well say something Club but I W um we
have all been set an amendment 377 which
one I see a few more heads raised I'm
presume people have looked at in a few
seconds and then I'm recognize the of
to Madam chair I had a great deal of
you we we are about to consider an
hb77 so representative Barry why don't
talk about the bill and what your
Amendment does thank you um yes Madam
chairman so we heard testimony um about
hb77 which just refresh our memory is
requiring the city and town flarks to
report daily to the Secretary of State's
office the people who have registered to
work for office um there's a couple
issues raised um to two which are both
addressed in this amendment the first of
which is that there is current stat
um which is RSA
6558 so instead of creating a new
section we're just going to go into the
existing section which deals with the
clerks notifying the Secretary of
State's office of the fil for office um
and the second one uh which was raised
which is what do we do with um clks who
aren't especially for smaller towns for
clerks who are not open um five days a
week so what the what the second what
the second part of this amendment does
is it clarifies that if your off if the
clerk's office is not open and receiving
um filings for office that they do not
have to report so they if they are open
and they are receiving they have to
report if they're not open and they're
not receiving they do not have and I'm
happy to answer any I didn't work with
the original sponsor of this bill um on
the amendment he approves of it and I'm
obviously happy to answer any questions
i i i w to actually read the amendment
on if somebody has it and put forward it
to
this david. scan at I can do that SOS do
I just did that Madam chair he's got it
all right okay um because what it
provides for people that may be
listening is City and town clerk provide
to the Secretary of State on at least a
daily basis a summary of any filings
received pursuant to this chapter each
day such summary shall be submitted
electronically and shall include the
name and address of any candidate who is
filed the Secretary of State shall then
add those persons to the Daily report
for that day clerk shall only be
required to report to the Secretary of
State pursuant to this section on days
the clerk's offices are open and
all right questions from committee
didn't representative berd thank you
madam chairman um and maybe this would
be better answered by deputy scandin if
if the chair would allow it but uh I'll
direct the question to the sponsor of
the amendment first
um and thank you for the amendment it it
does correct the the major issues I had
a concern with um however in the
alternative couldn't the the clerks or
shouldn't the clerks be able to send an
actual copy of the filing papers to the
Secretary of State rather than to create
a summary of those documents uh I mean
if we we made photo copies and scan them
or or just fax them up to the Secretary
of State then he's got the entire
documents in front of him which he can
begin processing as opposed to just a a
summary of name and address which which
may be typed incorrectly and not have
information that the Secretary of
State's office needs to begin the actual
processing of the
applications
represent so we we considered this um
and in the interest of passing the bill
we didn't want to we want to give the
bill the best chance to pass and you
know different town Clarks operate
differently they have different
equipment represented ver on personally
I I agree with you I I think that that
would be the best way to go about it but
I don't know the situation in every town
clerk's office and I think that this
legislation Pro needs to go forward um
and kind of I would love to work out I
guess what I'm saying I would love to
work out those details next next session
when this thing's already in place but I
prus yes my concern is the daily I think
daily is too much but perhaps it could
be amended to
weekly I think it's important there is a
a Time Factor that's important in
reporting these candidates so that's my
take on it thank you representative did
you want to respond as the proponent of
the amend I I just I disagree with the
representative I mean I believe we would
this anybody else um I I want to say
that I didn't mention it at the public
hearing but I think on that day or the
previous day the post office had
announced that we're about to get a rate
increase and we can expect slower
delivery in the future of US postal
um and I think representative Barry's
concerned that not every town clerk is
going to be scanning these documents and
sending them off I be doing it now right
there's nothing that prohibits them from
forwarding it by scanning the the
document but I think the Secretary of
State wants the original so that sort of
mandates the mailing and we know the
mailing is not very efficient so
um I the only issue I see with this
amendment is that you're you're filling
out a summary and that could be done in
an email so I would think that would be
pretty easy for most clerks to do that
most clerks would have email the only
thing I see is that then the Secretary
of State if they reviewed the paperwork
what that followed on the actual form
and found out that the person wasn't
qualified then they're going back sort
of retroactively to pull somebody from
the list
but I don't know how often that actually
happens and if that's a legitimate
concern but I have real concerns going
forward that as these original forms get
nailed we're gonna really start to see
delays I know I'm seeing it in mail
right now in the state mailed within the
state used to be overnight um I'm happy
if it gets there in three
days Deputy Stan do you have any comment
on on my concern about a list as
compared to the actual form for checking
yes thank you madam chair um you're
absolutely right we we would want to
have the original Declaration of
candidacy forms in our possession during
or as soon after the filing period
closes as we can get them um I think
it's a good idea to ask the clerks to
send us who had filed uh electronically
so that uh we have that information what
it may mean though is that we keep uh
two lists on the website one is The
Unofficial list of filings submitted To
Us by the clerks electronically and then
the other would be the official list of
candidates who uh you know we have
confirmed as qualified based on our
quick review of The Declaration of
receive okay other questions on this
okay um I'm not seeing any so
ask the r on a motion to amend House
202-02
each representative mcdonal
yes representative Brian yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
payward yes representative M yes
representative to roian
yeses Barry yes representative gr yes
representative qua
yes CL says yes representative
Cody yes representative Cody can I see
you for a second again I was on a
different screen Madam chair hold on a
second great thank you hello
representative Ward yes representative
Bon
yes
representative
no representative
frus yes
representative H
yes representative
mad
yes
19 all right the amendment to House Bill
77 has passed so the motion on
the bill
sit amended is there a motion on the
bill as amended
representative yes Madam chairman I
amended is there a second moved and
seconded
byan do you wish to speak to your motion
Representative no ma'am I don't feel
it's necessary does anybody else wish to
speak to the motion on the
floor um yes Madam chair representative
Cody I do think the amendment improved
the bill but I think there are still
some issues about the
summary problem and so I will vote
no thank you any other comments I will
say it would appear that issues with the
current
practice um so I'm hoping that this bill
at amended if it passes will get us a
little closer to getting those problems
ironed
out any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask first to
representative McDonald yes
representative CR bran yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
Hayward yes representative Looney yes
representative toosan yes representative
Barry yes representative gr yes
representative quy
yes
yes representative Cody
no representative Ward
no representative
a
no Representative hyr
no representative Lane
no Representative
frus
yes all right representative Hamlet was
said a
yes yes and representative fedas did you
say something you're voting yes also is
that true okay
representative
youread
yes and the chair votes yes and
representative Cody if I could just see
your face again for that
vote for which vote for the vote you
just made vote no on the otpa on
77 I thought you did but
okay all right thank you all right and
what's the vote okay so the count is 14
to six so the motion carries 14 to six
um this will not be in the consent
calender nor will the previous bill um
if somebody can let me know as to
whether there'll be a Minority
Report it's today Wednesday by tomorrow
afternoon I was frankly hoping to have
reports in
today for what bills I suspect I could
get the calendar opened but um
suspected we could get bills that we
voted on today in the calendar as long
as we have reports in by the end of the
day but I recognize that that's a little
optimistic so um if you want to do a
report please let me know and we'll try
to get it in the calendar and if not for
next week and if not we'll have to wait
for a session in March my goal is to get
it is to try and get some of these
builds in the calendar for next week
because I have a fear that our calendars
are just going to grow ins size for
voting as we go on for this
session thank you the next bill before
us is House Bill
223 is a bill relative to political
party access to a list of
absentee ballot
requests is there a motion on this
representative SW thank you madam chair
a
second second
representative second representative
Sweeny would you like to speak to your
motion absolutely thank you madam chair
uh this bill authorizes political
parties to request and subscribe to the
absente ballot request list from the
secretary of state currently only
candidates can request and subscribe to
the absente ballot list of requests and
for the political parties to get access
to that data a candidate has to note the
party as the agent by allowing political
parties to request their own
subscriptions of the absente bot request
list will ensure that the respective
political parties can always have access
to this data throughout the political
cycle in the case they don't have an
B I would urge the committee to vot
pass are there any further comments from
represent thank you is there a reason
why it's only for Statewide ballot
[Music]
UMES um So currently the the Statewide
subscription the secretary of state
offers is
Statewide um all candidates with
candidates down ballot within specific
districts can go to their Town clerks
that the clerks within their District to
get the data um but currently the
subscription allows for Statewide
candidates to get the the subscription
in the request list so this would just
be extending that to local parties same
L thank
hearing are there any other questions I
I'm not often requesting Statewide
discussion or questions on the motion on
223 I'm seeing none so I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the
role representative McDonald yes
representative T O'Brien yes
representative swen yes representative
Hayward yes representative Mooney yes
representative toosan yes representative
Barry yes representative gr yes
representative
qu says yes representative Cody no
representative Cody I need to see you
again people are gonna talk if I keep
using
this hold
on here I
am no
and and the vote is no I got it thank
you
PTF no representative
HR
no representative Lane no
Representative
frus
Hamet
yes so the OT motion on
h223 passes 11
to9 the next bill we have is
263 relative to campaign Finance
amendment
2021 does someone want to make a motion
in regards to the amendment
representative SW yes Madam chair I move
we amend House Bill 263 with Amendment
202-
3338 speak is there a second second
seconded by representative tros and
representative Sweeny you can speak to
your motion and can you please take us
through the amendment because
um absolutely so so this amendment
actually came out of the public hearing
that we had on the bill on Bill on House
Bill 263 uh it restores the ability for
candidates to file as candidates with
the Secretary of State's office I had
originally removed that from the initial
draft of the proposed legislation uh but
after the public hearing and and
questions from committee members
regarding it i s I thought it would be
right to put that back into the
legislation um and I also amended it to
increase the threshold for reporting uh
currently if a if a candidate committee
or political committee spends more than
$500 or raises more than $500 they
report to the secretary state's office
this updates that level uh to $1,500 in
receipts or expenditures um and the
inspiration with that was also from the
public hearing and also in line with a
bill from representative Edwards uh that
we had already exec last week in which
we're updating the reporting thresholds
for individual donations uh this
proposal moves it up not at the same
rate as we're changing the the $25 to
$100 but just the $500 to
$1,500 and I would say I I expect most
campaigns running in competitive
districts would spend more than $1,500
in the election it's just been a
significant amount of time since uh that
threshold was put into law and it's just
updating it to meet the current
realities that we live in so that's
that's the Crux of this amendment
everything else bill is the same as it
introduced questions from committee
amendment
Peter um representative Sweeney just
because I if I look at HB 263 and I look
um section one is gone right section one
has been removed because that was the
change to candidate and candidate
committee so that is now no longer in
the
bill and then section
five you have
amended
um so candidate is back in section five
it added in candidate or a candidate
okay that's the only change in the
amendment I missed that okay and and
that's the change then
in um seven also is you've now left it
as
is for candidate and candidate
committee and so
then uh in section five you get to the
500 to the $1,500 limit that you would
talking about in regards to the other
one so section four is new is new right
uh so it's section five yep uh I don't
believe it's new it's just changing the
current section
of right that's what I meant but as to
the bill as to the bill it's new to the
it's again changing the amount from 500
to
1500 and then
section seven is the same as in the
original
yes you get to these things being longer
the
amendment I'm not seeing any so I'm
going to ask the cler to call the role
on the floor is amendment
263 representative McDonald yes
representative food hel O'Brien yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
Hayward yes representative Mooney yes
representative toosan yes representative
Barry yes representative gr yes
representative quy yes says yes
no no
can I see for a
sec
thanks representative
Ward
no representative B on
no
say
no I know just get my head
representative h
no representative Lane
no Representative
frus
no representative pamplet on
mute so sorry
no thank you representative your head
so be 11
to9 thank you not seeing any further
amendments is there a
motion uh for
OTP excuse me a motion we just moved
that on the amendment is there a motion
on 263 as amended
Representatives Madam chair I move House
Bill 263 ought to pass as am is there a
second second seconded by representative
Bill I'm not seeing any so I'm ask theer
call the representative McDonald yes
representative F O'Brien yes
representative Sween yes representative
heward yes representative Mooney yes
representative rosan yes
representative Barry yes representative
Gro yes representative quy
yes yes representative Cody
no representa
Cody
represent
no
no representative Lane
no Representative
frus no representative HL
no representa your head no not to you
yes 11 to9 thank you uh the vote is
11-9 26 three will go on the calendar as
an
OTP as amended um for this bill and
other bills if I could know by the end
of the day if there's GNA be report that
would be
terrific by the end of the day guess I
o' I'll do the best I can Madam
chair I said I'll do the best I can I
know you are can't make these decisions
is you know what every day I'm a little
um next bill
is
326 this is the bill requiring town and
City Clerks to make
electronic lists of absentee ballot
requests public hearing on this was
February
12 I have a motion on
326 representative bar yes mam chairman
I move that we op to pass AGB
326 is there a second I second that
representative' bran second it would you
like speak to your motion representative
very Madam chairman um fellow members of
the committee as we established in the
hearing HP 326 is
bipartisan bill that in a very small Way
modernizes New Hampshire's electoral
process around absente
to
questions questions from committee
elect um I actually have a question
representative Barry that I the two
things I show as just as being discuss
with this bill I'm not sure that they
impact the the vote but um we just had
two amendments and I don't see one on
this there was some discussion of copies
versus data file um and I see that you
have chosen not to change that there was
also some discussion of P schedules
which I be a whole different statute but
why did you keep with the copies um I
kep with the copies mam chairman because
while I do actually believe a data file
would be U easier on the cler they could
provide the data file that would saice
with this with the this legislation but
I I think this legislation need to go
into place and then as the clerks get
used to it we can make it to where it
needs to be perfectly um as to your
other part about the fee structure I
would also like to eventually see a
scheduled fee structure put in but once
again I don't want to overreach on the
thank
members El I'm not see
326 representative Donal yes
representative yes representative swe
yes representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
thian yes representative Barry yes
representative gr yes representative qu
yes
yes representative Cody
no representa on
Sandler
sorry
no representative HR
no representative Lane
no Representative
crus no
represent
no representative your head no Madam
119 Minority
Report the next item on for vote this
afternoon is
468 468 is relative to the definition of
political advocacy
organization I have not received any
amendments is there a motion
representative Queen thank you madam
chair I would move House Bill 468 as in
to
legisl is there a
second second representative Barry
second Representatives like to speak to
the motion is itl 468 yes thank you
Madam chair uh this bill modifies the
definition of political advocacy
organizations for purposes of political
expenditure contribution laws there are
significant issues of organization and
enforceability with this proposed
legislation the types of free speech
that would be covered is far too broad
and the reduction from $5,000 in
spending as the reporting threshold to
$2,500 in spending that would be covered
by this legislation is a significant
change that could hurt smaller advocacy
groups uh frequently we have heard
testimony in this committee from an
unincorporated organization that refers
to itself as the P Street Coalition that
does not file with the Secretary of
State's office regards the activity they
do we should not punish unaffiliated and
in small groups like The casri Coalition
that engage in activity that this bill
would broadly pay his fcal advocacy when
they are simply educating the voters
utilizing the freedom of speech granted
to them under the United States
Constitution citing that in other
expedient is there anybody else who'
like to
speak to this motion I'll just clarify
for the record I think you're talking
about Miss Spencer in the Kent she
all right is there any further
468 see
none
theal
yes representa Brian yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Haywood yes
representative Mooney yes representative
to Roan yes representative Barry yes
representative BR yes represent qu
no
no representative
Lane surprisingly
[Music]
no Representative
frus
no represent C
no Representative
newad
no
yes 11 to
468 we'll go on the calendar is itl with
the vote of 11 to9 again if I can
there's gonna be a Minority Report by
the end of the day that Madam chair
there will be there will be a Minority
Report on 460 it but I don't think it
can be done by four o'clock all right
what I'm I'm gonna do if it's all right
representative Cody is I'm going to see
what majority blurs I can Wrangle out of
people here in the room before they
leave
I will tell you that is the thing I miss
the most about not having iners meetings
the ability to get things done before
they Representatives go on their way and
I will let you know what I've got and
maybe at the end of the day you can let
me know what ones you think you might
have a Minority Report and we'll be sure
to hold those I'm gonna vote yes thank
you all right the next item I have for
EXE session this afternoon is house go
476 relative to election officers at
additional polling
places this is a
repeating theme I think in front of this
motion representative I like to move
that to pass 47 six has been moved on to
pass is there a second mam
Charleson representative Sweeny second
it representative F Brian would you like
to speak to your motion yes I I uh
support this bill it would allow
moderators to look Beyond just their
their districts uh to find people to
work at the polls who uh are from their
this this would be beneficial to my
community
because we have changed our polling
places often would help moderators find
more people to work at the
PO for that reason I
support thank you is there any other
discussion on the motion that is on the
476 I'm not seeing any hands or further
discussion so I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the the motion on the floor is
OTP
476 representative McDonald yes
representative' BR yes representative
Sweeny yes representative haward yes
representative money yes representative
toosan yes representative Barry yes
representative BR yes representative quy
yes Marcus yes
representative Cody
yes representative Ward
yes representative B
yes
representative uh yes thank you
representative representative
hyr
yes representative Hamlet
yes representative newad
yes mad
yes right 20 to Z the vote is 20 to zero
if there's no objection this will go on
the consent
calendar thank you everybody uh the next
bill on the list to be voted on by this
committee is 489
prohibiting certain political
contributions there was a public hearing
on this bill on February 5th is there a
motion on this Bill yes Madam chairman I
move that HP 49 the in speed to
legislate representative Barry has moved
489 itl is there a second second
representative ter roian has seconded
would you like to speak to your motion
representative yes chairman um during
the testimony of HB 489 was brought to
light that this bill appears to be
targeted as a singular individual um as
such I cannot support this bill and I
legislate is there any further
discussion on
the
B hear very weird but I'm not seeing
anybody who wants to
speak all right I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role then on HB
489 representative
McDonald's yes representative O'Brian
yes representative Sweeny yes
representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
rosian yes representative Barry yes yes
representative Gro yes representative
no
no representative bon no
Representative
no Representative hyr no
[Music]
no representative
frus
NOA C
no Representative newad
no M
yes to n vote on I HB 489 in expediate
to legislate will'll go on the calendar
the last bill I have noticed for
executive session today is house bill
by4 this is relative to ballot column
representative I that
HB 514 is inexpedient to legisl I hope
I apologize to members of the committee
um is there someone else since
representative Barry appears to be
confused about what Bill we're on or
what he's
doing
McDonald representative McDonald has
moved that hb514 be retained is there a
second been seconded by
representative hey
representative McDonald would you like
to speak to your
motion yes Madam chairman um this is a
complex issue the committee has reviewed
it and still has questions and
deserves
work there any further discussion on
this my recollection is the Secretary of
State during the testimony spoke about
the the senson statute which was very
confusing
that the bill really needed an
amendment and
when they were asked when I asked about
their ability to work on the amendment
do the things going on right now they
were not able to work on it so um in
deference to the Secretary of State's
office who believes this needs to be
changed but frankly the impact would not
be till next year so there's no
Farm waiting to get the formula langage
right motion going support the motion to
retain Madam chair could I just ask what
sort of work is
contemplated uty if you're on the line I
will recognize you I think it's to come
up with some formula other than the one
that's in there because it's confusing
and the point of it quite frankly I'm
not really quite sure Deputy Stan do you
have something to add to the and to help
representative understand what we need
to do with this
yes Madam chair the the um the formula
that we have to apply to come up with a
standard that is as close to 1% as is
practical but in no event greater than
1% across the board for state
representative candidates Senate
candidates it gets easier as you get
higher but it is uh it is a very complex
formula that took a great deal of manh
hours in the last decade uh to come up
with if anybody in our office had to
explain how the formula worked we could
not uh there's one or two people that
understand it and um you know ideally we
would like to come up with a formula
that that satisfies the intent uh and
the uh uh well this just satisfies the
attent the spirit of the statute but in
a manner that we can tell candidates and
voters that you know this is how we
arrived at uh you know at at these uh
columns and um that's what we're trying
to
accomplish and would we would be happy
to have any of you participate in coming
up with that process that is so
you
discuss the bill on the motion on the
hb514 if
I no further discussion I'm going to
ask representative McDonald yes
representative yes representative Sweeny
yeah representative Hayward yes
representative M yes
representan yes representative Barry yes
representative BR yes
representative qu
yes yes representative Cody
yes representative Ward
you hear me yeah we can hear you are you
were yes or no on this oh I said yes
thank
you representative
HR yes representative
Lane
yes representative
frus
yes yes representative Yad yes
chman
yes to zero um House Bill 514 is
retained in committee the vote was 20 to
zero that concludes our executive
session
today I want to thank everybody for
attendance I want to thank
representative for substituting in with
us this
afternoon my goal is to not let anybody
out of this room until I hear about what
the status of reports is I will email
representative Cody and we'll see what
we can come up with before trying to get
things out today otherwise it will be in
one calendar for whenever we meet in
March is there any other business that
anybody has for the
committee representative to Roan so just
reiterate when our next committee
meeting I am not sure because that they
have not assigned official dates for the
first two weeks in March but I'm looking
for three days Wednesday and Friday the
first two weeks as soon as I have I will
send them out and then I'll do the work
of scheduling the bills but I'll let you
know what days as soon as I have them